ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
AND WITH THE LACK OF A QUORUM WE
WILL START AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'D LIKE --
EVERYONE TO PLEASE NOTE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL MURATSUCHI
HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAQUIN ARAMBULA
FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
AND WELCOME MISTER MAYER SU CHI.
ALSO WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM
DALY WHO'S BEEN APPOINTED TO
REPLACE MEMBER JACQUI IRWIN. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WELCOME MR DAILY.
ALSO WON A WELCOME BACK CHUCK
NICKEL.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF THAT
OUR LAST HEARING BUT HE WAS NOT
ON THE DíAS.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE HIS
PRESENCE TODAY.
WELCOME BACK CHUCK.
AND GLAD TO HAVE YOU BACK WITH
THIS -- AT
LEAST FOR THE THE TIME THAT
WE'RE HEARING MANY BILLS.
PLEASE NOTE THAT THE GENERAL
GUIDELINES FOR BILLS HEARD AND
COMMITTEE TODAY IS TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY FOR TWO WITNESSES FOR
TWO MINUTES.
AND THEN I WILL CALL FOR
TWEETERS.
THE MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES IN THE TWEENER CATEGORY
ONLY TWO WILL BE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND WE WILL BEGIN AND SIGN IN.
ALRIGHT WELL WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE WILL.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL FOLLOW THE
ROLE.
MEDINA PRESIDENT CHOI
[inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
BLOOM.
GABRIEL DAILY [inaudible]
KILEY LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT SO THE
COMMITTEE IS NOW --
IN FULL FORCE AND WE WILL BEGIN.
AND SIGNED IN ORDER AND WELCOME
OF TO THE DíAS.
MISS REYES.
AND WE ARE AN ITEM FOR A. B..
THREE EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF ON
THIS BILL.
AND I DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
AB THREE EIGHTY ONE SIMPLY
EXPANDS ON EXISTING ORIENTATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ARE REQUIRING EDUCATION.
AND PROGRAMMING ABOUT INTIMATE
PARTNER.
VIOLENCE MORE COMMONLY REFERRED
TO AS DATING AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN SURVEY. 80% OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN EXPERIENCE
PHYSICAL INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE WITHIN THEIR LIFETIMES.
WITH TRADITIONAL COLLEGE AGED
WOMEN.
BEING 11% MORE LIKELY TOOK OF
VIOLENCE.
THIS IS JUST A GROWS ONE
STUDENTS ARE ON COMMUTER HEAVY
CAMPUSES LIKE CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
CURRENTLY FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
REQUIRES.
COLLEGE CAMPUSES AS PART OF THE
ORIENTATION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAMMING TO DISCUSS ISSUES
RELATING TO SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
AB THREE EIGHTY ONE EXPANDS ON
THESE PROVISIONS ARE REQUIRES
THAT PROGRAMMING INCLUDE ALL
INFORMATION ABOUT INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE AND RELEVANT
RESOURCES ON CAMPUSES AS WELL AS
CREATION OF MEMORANDA OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH LOCAL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CENTERS.
WHEN FEASIBLE INCORPORATING
EDUCATION ON THE WARNING SIGNS
OF DATING AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE?
TRAINING ON THE PREVENTION OF
DATING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
COMMUNICATION ON CAMPUS.
ABOUT RESOURCES LAWS IMPULSES
POLICIES WHICH IMPACT AND CAN BE
UTILIZED BY THE STUDENTS WILL
HELP GIVE STUDENTS AN ARRAY OF
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO COMBAT.
THE HIGH RATES OF INTERPERSONAL
DATING AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WITH ME TODAY.
ARE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUTER COLLEGES IS
DANNY THERE ARE COOL.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES.
MY NAME IS DANNY TERKEL I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS DIRECTOR OF
REGION TO IN SACRAMENTO FOR THE
STUDENTS HAVE A CALIFORNIA COMEY
COLLEGE.
I ALSO SERVICED INTERESTED
PHILOSOPHY IS GOING TO COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
STUDENTS SENT FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE CULTURE SUPPORTED THIS
IN A ROW AND WE THINK THE OFFER
FOR COMMITMENT ON THE ISSUE.
THE REALITY WE'RE FACING IS.
TO MANY STUDENTS PARTICULARLY ON
A COMMUTER HEAVY CAMPUSES IN THE
COMMUNITY CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
OUR VICTIMS OR SURVIVORS OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE TOO
MANY STUDENTS FIND THEMSELVES IN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIPS AND ARE
UNCERTAIN OF WHERE TO FINALLY
SCISSORS RESOURCES FOR HELP OR
EVEN HOW TO IDENTIFY.
THAT THE RELATIONSHIP THEY ARE
IN AS ABUSIVE ALSO MENTAL IMPACT.
INDIVIDUALS IN A LONG TERM
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP.
MIGHT BELIEVE THAT THEY DESERVE
ABUSE FOR ANY SOMETHING THAT
THEY THOUGHT WAS WRONG.
BUT THEY DID NOTHING WRONG AND
NO ONE DESERVES ANY KIND OF
ABUSE.
MANY DO NOT LEAVE BECAUSE
THEY'RE SCARED.
AND SOME THAT DO WANT TO LEAVE
DON'T KNOW THE FIRST STEP TO
TAKE IN ORDER TO LEAVE SAFELY.
WITHOUT PROPER KNOWLEDGE THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL AND OVERALL
MANIPULATION BY AN AGGRESSOR
CONTINUES AND COUNTLESS OF
STUDENTS WILL CONTINUE TO STAY
SILENT.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL AS A MATTER
SAFETY FOR STUDENTS ENSURING
THAT CAMPUSES.
WHEN HAVING ORIENTATION PROGRAMS
FOCUSED ON SEXUAL SO EDUCATION
INCLUDE INFORMATIVE PROGRAMS?
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
INCLUDE PROGRAMS ON DATING AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS IMPERATIVE
PIECE OF COMBATING INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
AS FOR THESE REASONS AT THE
STUDENT CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THREE EIGHTY ONE AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU'RE ABLE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU'D COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE AND SAY YOU GET YOUR
NAME AND WHO YOU REPRESENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CUSTOMS A
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TEND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I ALLEYS AGO WITH OF MACINNES
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY WINNERS.
SEEN ANY UP [inaudible]
WIENER MAYBE --
HANNAH BACKSTAB WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION WALLER
BOARD HASN'T FORMALLY TAKEN A
POSITION ON THE SPELL WE SUPPORT
AND CONCEPT.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
I'LL SEE NONE --
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
AS CHAIR OF THE HIGHER ED
COMMITTEE I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING SURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS UNDERSTAND.
AS WHEN THEY COME IN --
THE PARAMETERS AND AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF ORIENTATION --
AT AS THEY COME IN A TO BEGIN.
A COLLEGE SO I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AS I SUPPORTED TWENTY SEVENTY
LAST YEAR WHEN I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH YOU.
AS THE MOVE AS THE BILL MOVES.
FOR WE HAVE A FIRST BY MISTER
LOWE A SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I BLOOM.
GABRIELLA [inaudible]
BLOOM I GABRIEL --
DAILY.
DALY I KILEY.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON
SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I EIGHT ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER NOW THAT THE NEXT THE
BILL ITEM NUMBER.
SIX MISS GONZALEZ [inaudible]
FLETCHER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE HUNDRED I'VE
BROUGHT BACK FROM LAST YEAR
WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS%
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO PROVIDE CERTIFIED
ACADEMIC AND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES.
AT LEAST SIX WEEKS OF FULLY PAID
LEAVE DUE TO PREGNANCY
MISCARRIAGE CHILDBIRTH RECOVERY.
TAKE PREGNANCY RELATED LEAVE OF
ABSENCE CURRENT LAW FORCES
SCHOOL AN ACADEMIC EMPLOYEES
EXHAUST ALL ACCRUED LEAVE
INCLUDING PAID SICK LEAVE AND
VACATION TIME.
BEFORE THEY CAN RECEIVE ONLY
DIFFERENTIAL PAY AND THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE INCOME IS
LEFT FOR THE EMPLOYEE AFTER THE
DISTRICT HAS PAID FIRST
SUBSTITUTE POSITION.
AND WE'RE PERSONS OVER 70%
FEMALE THIS POLICY DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST WOMEN WHO CHOOSE TO HAVE
CHILDREN.
FORCES THEM TO DEPLETE ANY PAID
LEAVE THEY'VE ACCRUED AND WE
KNOW THAT PAID LEAVE IS VERY
IMPORTANT ONCE THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT CHILD.
AND SACRIFICE THEIR FINANCIAL
SECURITY IN ORDER TAKE NEXT.
I REDUCES BILL BECAUSE IT'S
CLEAR THAT PUTTING YOUNG WOMEN
IN A POSITION WHERE THEY MUST
CHOOSE BETWEEN SCHEDULING
PREGNANCIES BASED ON ACADEMIC
YOUR CALENDAR WAITING YEARS TO
HAVE CHILDREN UNTIL THEY'VE
SAVED ENOUGH SICK LEAVE.
OR TEMPING TO SURVIVE WITHOUT
ADEQUATE PAY IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
OR SUSTAINABLE RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT IF THE STATE
COULD CUT THE TURNOVER RATE FOR
TEACHERS AND HALF THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE WOULD BE LARGELY
ELIMINATED THIS IS ONE STEP IN.
DOING THAT SCHOOLS IN COMEY
COLLEGES CAN HELP ENSURE
EMPLOYEES ARE SO INCENTIVIZE TO
REMAIN IN THE PROFESSION.
ESPECIALLY AFTER THEY'VE HAD
CHILDREN BY INVESTING IN
NECESSARY BENEFITS THAT MAKE IT
LESS BURDENSOME FOR YOUNG WOMEN
TO START A FAMILY.
AB FIVE HUNDRED WHAT ALSO HELP
ENSURE THE THAT'S POSSIBLE BY
SIMPLY REQUIRING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOL DEGREE
COLLEGES REVISED EMPLOYEES WITH
AT LEAST SIX WEEKS OF PAID
PREGNANCY LEAVE WHICH THEY
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE.
HAVE A NUMBER OF WITNESSES HERE
TO TESTIFY.
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GAIL PIPPEN I'MA PSYCHOLOGY
PROFESSOR AND PRESIDENT OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE AT SACRAMENTO
CITY COLLEGE THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
CFT APPLAUDS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GONZALEZ FOR OFFERING AB FIVE
HUNDRED THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
AFFECTS SO MANY PEOPLE INCLUDING
MYSELF.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IN TIGHT TO WHY WE
NEED AB FIVE HUNDRED TO BE
SIGNED INTO LAW.
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT I'M SORRY.
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I
GAVE BIRTH TO MY FIRST AND ONLY
CHILD MY EMPLOYER THE LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
GRANTS ONE DAY.
OF PAID LEAVE FOR CHILDBIRTH.
UNLIKE PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYEES
MOST FACULTY LIKE MYSELF ARE NOT
COVERED BY STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE AND THAT'S TO NOT
RECEIVE ANY TYPE OF PAID LEAVE
UNDER THAT PROGRAM.
I CHOSE TO TAKE THE ENTIRE
SEMESTER OFF BUT THE ONLY WAY I
COULD DO THAT WAS TO TAKE UNPAID
LEAVE AND TO LOSE A STEP IN MY
SALARY ADVANCEMENT.
THOSE WERE SACRIFICES I WAS
WILLING TO MAKE AND RECOVER BUT
COST.
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE NOT
BEEN SO FORTUNATE ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES GAVE BIRTH TOOK HER
ONE DAY OF PAID LEAVE AND RETURN
TO WORK.
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE HAD A BABY
TOOK UNPAID LEAVE AND DECIDED
NOT TO RETURN STILL ANOTHER
COLLEGE PROBABLY QUIT TEACHING
AS AN ADJUNCT INSTRUCTOR AFTER
HAVING HER SECOND CHILD.
THEN WAS NEVER ABLE TO REENTER
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE WORK FORCE.
THESE EXAMPLES ALONE DEMONSTRATE
THE DISCRIMINATORY NATURE OF ARE
CURRENTLY POLICIES FOR
CALIFORNIA EDUCATORS.
WE LIVE IN THE US ONE OF THE
WEALTHIEST AND MOST
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED NATIONS
IN THE WORLD AND YET THE US IS
THE ONLY INDUSTRIALIZED COUNTRY
AND ONE OF THREE COUNTRIES
OVERALL.
WITH NO PAID PARENTAL LEAVE THIS
IS NOT GOOD FOR EDUCATIONAL WORK
FORCE AND IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
STUDENTS.
PARENTAL LEAVE INCREASES
WORKPLACE LOYALTY AND
CONTRIBUTES TO EMPLOYEE
RETENTION CONTRARY TO POPULAR
BELIEVE IT'S SAVE THE STATE
MONEY.
IMPROVES WORKPLACE PRODUCTIVITY
WHICH MEANS WERE ABLE TO GIVE
OUR BEST SELVES TO OUR STUDENTS
AND LET'S NOT FORGET OUR
CHILDREN OUR FUTURE.
AND SUPPLYING THE BASICS FOR
FAMILIES IT'S ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS WE CAN GIVE OUR FUTURE
COMMUNITY LEADERS A STRONG START
IN LIFE.
I WILL PERSONALLY BENEFIT FOR
MAYBE FIVE HUNDRED BUT MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIA EDUCATORS WELL
CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE THE LEAD ON
PULLING THE U. S. OUT OF THE
BOTTOM INTERNATIONAL POSITION
FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
MORE OVER EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
WILL HELP KEEP VALUED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES IN THE WORK FORCE
AFTER HAVING CHILDREN AFTER
HAVING CHILDREN AN END TO THE
CURRENT CURRENT DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICE. FOR THESE REASONS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
VERONICA Là PASS I AM AN
ATTRITION FACULTY AT AMERICAN
RIVER COLLEGE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TO THIS
BILL.
THE UNITED STATES IS ONE OF A
HANDFUL OF COUNTRIES THAT DON'T
HAVE A NATIONAL PARENTAL PAID
LEAVE POLICY WHEN A WOMAN IN THE
U. S. GETS PREGNANT SHE'S
ENTITLED TO TWELVE WEEKS OF
UNPAID LEAVE WITHIN TWELVE
MONTHS AFTER BIRTH.
THANKS TO A CLINTON ERA A LOT
KNOWN AS THE FAMILY MEDICAL
LEAVE ACT.
BUT AMERICAN WOMEN ARE NOT
AUTOMATICALLY ENTITLED TO TWELVE
FULLY PAID WEEKS OFF LIKE WOMEN
IN MAY HE GO OR FORTY SIX FULLY
PAID WEEKS OFF LIKE IN WOMEN IN
BULGARIA.
OTHER COUNTRIES WITHOUT NATIONAL
PARENTAL PAID LEAVE INCLUDES
WHAT YOU AND LESS THOUGH PULL
BUT NEW GUINEA.
THIS LACK OF POLICY ISN'T JUST
INCONVENIENCE FOR AMERICAN WOMEN
IN MANY CASES IT DETERMINES HOW
WOMEN MAKE CRUCIAL CHOICES ABOUT
THEIR HEALTH.
THEIR FINANCES AND THEIR
FAMILIES TEACHERS ARE HIT
PARTICULARLY HARD BY THE SLACK
BECAUSE ROUGHLY 75% OF PUBLIC TO
SCHOOL TEACHERS ARE WOMEN.
AND WE ARE GROSSLY UNDERPAID.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WEEKLY
WAGES WERE ROUGHLY 17% LOWER
THAN THOSE COMPATIBLE WORKERS
ACCORDING TO THE ECONOMIC POLICY
INSTITUTE.
LAST YEAR SOME PEOPLE TEACHERS
IN NEW YORK GOT SOME GOOD NEWS
AFTER A LONG BATTLE WITH NEW
YORK CITY THE UNITED FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS SUCCESSFULLY HELP
IMPLEMENT A POLICY GIVING PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHERS. SIX WEEKS OF
PAID PARENTAL LEAVE.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE LEGISLATOR
CALIFORNIA OFFERS ITS EMPLOYEES
OF LEGISLATOR THE UC AND THE CSU
SIX WEEKS OF PAID PARENTAL LEAVE.
NEW YORK SAKE OFFERS ITS
EMPLOYEES EIGHT WEEKS OF PAID
PARENTAL LEAVE.
NEW JERSEY PROGRAM OFFERS SIX
WEEKS OF PAID LEAVE A BUT
EMPLOYEES ARE PAID ONLY TWO
THIRDS OF THEIR NORMAL PAYCHECKS.
AUSTIN TEXAS IN PITTSBURGH ALSO
OFFERS TEACHERS SIX WEEKS OF
PAID PARENTAL LEAVE AS EVIDENCE
SHOWS CALIFORNIA IS FALLING
BEHIND WE CAN DO BETTER AND WE
SHOULD DO BETTER.
AB FIVE HUNDRED WILL HELP RETAIN
VALUABLE SCHOOL EMPLOYEES THIS
IS AN INVESTMENT THAT OUR
SCHOOLS MUST MAKE.
THIS IS NOT A SUBSIDY I URGE YOU
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA CALL FOR A OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF YOU GIVE
YOUR NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE PROP CO SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S JOHN A PERSON ASK HIM
PRESIDENT OF THE PROLIFERATION
OF TEACHERS AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN AT THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE'RE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
GALLERY NESBITT I'M A PART TIME
INSTRUCTOR FOR SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND I
SUPPORT BILL.
CATHERINE NEVER GONE ON BEHALF
OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
ANDREAS LATER PART TIME FACULTY
MEMBER AT LANEY COLLEGE AND
SUPPORT THIS.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBER
GONZALEZ --
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
A FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE --
I'M THAT BY.
A YEAR AGO I SON AND MY FIRST
GRAND CHILD.
AND JUST AFTER ONE YEAR.
HE IS NOW BARELY --
YOU KNOW HIS CELL PHONE.
CAPTION WALKING RUNNING ETCETERA
AND THE FLOW OF SIX MONTHS.
OF TIME.
I THOUGHT THE PERSONALLY WAS SO
UNNECESSARY AFTER TIES BUT THE
FOR OF THE CHILDREN AND ALMOST A
MONTH A MONTH THIS HOUSE A SELF.
BUT HERE MINIMUM --
SIX WEEKS OF LEAVE.
AFTER BIRTH THIS IS I THINK THAT
THAT'S A BABY STEP FUNDING.
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS SO --
SOMETHING WE CAN OR SUPPORT.
AND THEN I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
SHE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS --
MS GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE ABOUT.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IN
THE BILL FORWARD.
AND AS I SUPPORTED --
YOUR ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT TWO YEARS AGO I'M AGAIN
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AS A MATTER OF EQUITY.
SO IF I COULD HAVE A MOTION --
BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY MISTER
LOW.
AND MADAM SECRETARY BE GOOD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI AYE CHOI
AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY.
DALY I KILEY.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER HI. ELEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT.
I WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM --
NUMBER.
TWO AB.
ONE FIFTY FOUR OF MISTER VOEPEL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CHAIR [inaudible]
AND MY ILLUSTRIOUS AND HONORED
COLLEAGUES.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB ONE FIFTY
FOUR WHICH ESTABLISHES A STUDENT.
FINANCIAL AID PILOT PROGRAM TO
EXAMINE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF AN
INCOME CHAIR AGREEMENT AS A
FUNDING SOURCE FOR STUDENTS
EARNING THEIR BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN ARE UC AND CSU SYSTEM
COMMENCING BUT THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO YEAR.
UNDER AND I ESSAY IN COME CHAIR
AGREEMENT PRIVATE INVESTORS FUND
STUDENTS IN RETURN FOR A SHARE
OF THEIR INCOME OVER FIX PERIODS
OF TIME.
PURDUE UNIVERSITY HAS
IMPLEMENTED A PROGRAM SUCH AS
THIS AS A WAY TO PROVIDE AN
ALTERNATIVE SOLUTION TO MOUNTING
DEBT.
AND IT'S HELPED OVER FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE CS USED
TO TAKE ASK.
IN I PUT EMPHASIS ON BIG IN A
WHIMPERING.
ASK UC'S TO PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATION WILL BE BASED ON
THE LEVEL OF PRIVATE INVESTMENT
WHILE THE STATE WOULD FUND THE
UP FRONT COST OF THE INITIAL
PROGRAM.
WELL THE MIX OF FEDERAL AND
STATE GRANTS IS AVAILABLE FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THE AMOUNT
IS FREQUENTLY IN SUFFICIENT TO
COVER THE COSTS OF ATTENDANCE.
THESE STUDENTS MUST OFTEN TAKE
OUT LOANS TO BRIDGE THE FUNDING
GAP UNLIKE PRIVATE OR STUDENT
LOANS THERE IS NO INTEREST
CHARGED WITH AYE ESSAYS IT'S
KINDA NEAT THAT WAY.
INCOME SHARE AGREEMENTS PROVIDE
ANOTHER FINANCING OPTIONS TO
HELP ALLEVIATE THE MONETARY
BURDEN ON STUDENTS EARNING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREES.
THE INSURER THE I. SA MONTHLY
PAYMENTS ARE ADJUSTED ACCORDING
TO THE STUDENTS POSTGRADUATE
INCOME AND DID NOT BEGIN UNTIL
THE STUDENTS EMPLOYED EARNING
THE MINIMUM SALARY REQUIREMENT
OF TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THE AVERAGE.
LOAN THAT A STUDENT KERRY'S WHEN
THEY GRADUATE IS TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A NEAT PROGRAM
[inaudible]
I APPRECIATE.
THE DEDICATION THE CALIFORNIA'S
COLLEGE STUDENTS ESPECIALLY BY
THIS COMMITTEE.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE CASEY JENNINGS WITH
THE THIRTEENTH AVENUE FUNDING TO
TELL YOU MORE IN REGARDS TO THE
PROGRAM.
AND WHERE THE MONEY COMES FROM.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S CASEY
JENNINGS.
I'M THE CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
NOT FOR PROFIT THIRTEENTH AVENUE
FUNDING.
WE STARTED ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO
TO FOCUS ON INCOME SHARE
AGREEMENTS.
WE WERE ADVISERS TO PRODUCE
UNIVERSITIES PROGRAM.
WITH ADVISED A COUPLE OTHER
PROGRAMS.
WE'VE TALKED TO INVESTORS WE'VE
TALKED TO COLLEGES WE TALK TO
TEACHERS WE TALKED TO A LOT OF
STUDENTS.
PRIOR TO THIS WORK I SPENT
THIRTY YEARS BASICALLY ON WALL
STREET CREATING STRUCTURED
FINANCE PRODUCTS.
I GOT INVOLVED IN AYE ESSAYS
BECAUSE I NOTICES STUDENTS WERE
BORROWING MORE.
MUCH MORE.
BUT THE OUTCOMES WERE NOT
GETTING BETTER.
AND THE RISK OF THAT INCREASED
BORROWING WAS BEING BORNE BY THE
STUDENTS.
IN MY FORMER CAREER HAVING THE
WEAKEST PARTY IN A TRANSACTION
BEAR ALL THE RISK WAS ALWAYS THE
WRONG DEAL.
THOSE DEALS BLOW UP THEIR HARM
EVERYBODY INVOLVED WITH THEM.
THAT'S OUR STUDENT LOAN SYSTEM
IS IS WHAT IS HEADING.
FOR IT'S PRETTY FAR DOWN THAT
ROAD.%
THE ISSUE A STERN DOES A CURLY
STRUCTURED IS THAT DEBT BEING
BORNE BY THE WEAKEST PARTY THE
STUDENTS THE FALL RATES RISE
STUDENTS WILL BE UNABLE TO PAY.
AND THE TAXPAYERS GONNA WRITE
THE CHECK.
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT.
I ESSAYS OFFER THE POTENTIAL. TO
MOVE SOME OF THAT ROSE FROM THE
STUDENTS TO A PARTY BETTER ABLE
TO BEAR THAT RISK.
BUT I WANT TO KEEP IN MIND I
SAID POTENTIAL.
THERE ARE GOOD I SAY IS THERE
ARE ABOUT.
SIX I WANT TO TURN TO THE LETTER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION.
SOME OF THE DETAILS CONCERNING
IOS IS NOT LETTER INCORRECT.
I DON'T WANT TO FOCUS ON THAT.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE ON SAID
ASSUMPTION LETTER.
THE LETTER ASSUMES THAT AYE
ESSAYS ARE NOT ALREADY AVAILABLE.
IN CURRENTLY BEING USED BY CSU
STUDENTS.
BUT THEY ARE BEING USED.
THAT SCALE.
MY CURRENT STUDENTS BY RECENT
GRADUATES AND BY POTENTIAL
STUDENTS. FOR WHOM GOING TO
COLLEGE PROPOSES TO MUCH
FINANCIAL RISK.
SO WHERE THEY USING THOSE MOST
IN ARE USING AN PURSUE
CERTIFICATES FROM PROGRAMMING
BOOT CAMPS.
I'M SURE USING THE ADS ABOUT
HALF OF ALL THE PROGRAMMING BOOT
CAMPS THE I'D STATES IN
CALIFORNIA.
A GOOD PORTION OF THOSE BOOT
CAMPS ARE FUNDED BY THE STUDENTS
SIGNING ISA'S.
THERE'S NO OVERSIGHT THERE'S NO
REGULATION THERE'S NO OFFERING
[inaudible]
IN FACT.
UC SAN DIEGO'S EXTENSION PROGRAM
IS ENTERED A JOINT VENTURE WITH
A WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GROUP IN
SAN DIEGO.
IT'S GOING TO KICK OFF IN JULY
WITH ITS FIRST CLASS AND THE
STUDENTS HAVE THE OPTION OF
SIGNING INTO INCOME SHARE
AGREEMENTS.
SO BETWEEN THE BOOT CAMPS.
THE UC EXTENSION AND ALL THE
PROGRAMS WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
THESE ARE ALREADY OUT THERE SO I
RESPECT THE FACT RECESS ASIAN.
BUT HAVING SEE IF YOU SAY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO DO IT.
I DON'T THINK ACTUALLY SOLVES
THE PROBLEM [inaudible]
SO.
I THINK THEY HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TRANSFER RISK.
BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S UNCLEAR
THAT'S HAPPENING.
THE REASON WHY ORGANIZATION
SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
IS BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S MUCH
BETTER HAVE CSU AND UC SPONSOR
AYE ESSAYS THAN THE CURRENT
FRAME.
WE THINK THERE HAVE GOOD FOR THE
HAVE IMPROVED DISCLOSURE
INCREASED CHANCE PARENTING
BETTER TERMS AND CONDITIONS FOR
THE STUDENT. FOR AMOUNT OF
OVERSIGHT PROBABLY A LOT OF
DISCUSSION.
NONE OF THAT'S CURRENTLY
HAPPENING WITH AYE ESSAYS IN
CALIFORNIA.
A WELL STRUCTURED I ESSAY WILL
TRANSFER THE MAJORITY OF THE
RISK.
FROM THE POOL OF STUDENTS TO
THIRD PARTIES.
HAVING THIS LEGISLATURE FUND A
PILOT PROGRAM WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY OFFERED A BETTER I
SAY TO CALIFORNIANS.
HAND SINCE I'M FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR --
FOR THIRTY STAND OF THE OTHER
PROVIDERS WILL HAVE TO UP THEIR
GAME.
BECAUSE THIS WILL BECOME THE
BENCHMARK PRODUCT THIS WEEK ON
WHAT STUDENTS WILL LOOK AT AND
THEY'LL HAVE SOME TRANSFERRED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT A GOOD I SAY IS
FROM A BAD I SAY.
SO.
IF WE DO NOTHING.
CRITICIZED THE EXISTING SYSTEM
IS JUST FINE.
THEN WE WON'T HAVE THAT WON'T
HAPPEN.
AND THE STUDENTS WILL CONTINUE
TO BEAR RISK.
AND WE WON'T SEE.
THAT'S ALL I GOT TO SAY THANKS
FOR YOUR TIME I'LL STOP AND TAKE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
AND BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER I'D
LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR IF HE
ACCEPTS THE AMENDMENTS.
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU --
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THREE NINE ANY WITNESSES AGAINST.
MR MEMBERS ANDREW ANTS WE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION --
WE'VE BEEN ON RECORD WITH OUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS PROPOSAL --
WHERE TO STAND THE GOOD
INTENTIONS AND FRANKLY THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR REFINING THE BILL?
BUT THE UNDERLYING PREMISE OF
HAVING PRIVATE INVESTORS PROVIDE
THIS TYPE OF FINANCIAL AID IT'S
NOT A BETTER ALTERNATIVE TO
PUBLICLY FUNDED FINANCIALLY.
AND IT COULD BE A PATHWAY
TOWARDS WAY SO HERE IS
QUESTIONABLE.
AND WE'RE CONCERNED BECAUSE OF
STUDENTS ARE DESPERATE TO GET A
HIGHER EDUCATION WE REALLY
BELIEVE OF THE AUTHOR IN A
SPONSOR --
HAVE GOOD INTENTIONS HERE BUT WE
THINK THAT EVEN WITH THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEES
MADE.
OF THE BETTER ALTERNATIVE IS TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL AID.
AND WE'D RATHER SEE A STUDENT
GOING DOWN THAT PATHWAY.
THEN.
MAKE THEMSELVES YOU KNOW
AVAILABLE TO THIS KIND OF A
SITUATION WHERE THEIR FUTURE
INCOME AFTER THEY LEAVE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY NOT NECESSARILY
GRADUATE --
HAVE THEIR WAY JUST GARDENERS.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
CONTINUE TO RETAIN OPPOSITION
NOT WITHSTANDING THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AUTHOR JUST ACCEPTED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE WINNERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
SO THANK YOU WELL --
FOR THE PRESENTATION AND MISTER
AND TO BE.
FOR THE CIP FACE POSITION I I I
I I I GUESS SAY OF IT SEEMS LIKE
IT'S IT'S PROVIDING A AN OPTION.
FOR STUDENTS IN ADDITION TO
FINANCIAL AID AND SO IT'S NOT A
LITTLE FINANCIAL AID --
BY.
I GUESS I CAN'T SAY THAT I
UNDERSTAND.
WHY SEE IF THEY WOULD BE OPPOSED
TO IT OTHER THAN THE?
GENERAL PHILOSOPHY OF WEIGHTS
GARDEN GARNISHMENT MAN IT IT IT
IT SEEMS LIKE.
THIS WOULD HAVE THE YOU KNOW IT
STUDENTS AND A UNIVERSITIES HAVE
THE OPTION OF OF DECIDED WHETHER
OR NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM LOTS OF DIFFERENT.
FINANCIAL.
TOOLS YOU KNOW COMING BEFORE
STUDENTS SPECIALLY IN THERE IN A
COLLEGE YEARS.
AND MANY OF THEM AT THE TIME ARE
SEEN AS OPTIONS AND SOME PEOPLE
INCLUDING ME --
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THOSE AND THEN
LATER ON REGRETTED THEM OR HAD
TO PAY A HIGHER PRICE ON THEM --
THIS IS INNOVATIVE IN THE IDEA
OF ACCORDING TO SPONSORS NO
INTEREST ON IT.
BUT WE THINK THAT IF THE
UNIVERSITY IS GOING TO
EXPERIMENT WITH PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE TO
STUDENTS.
BUT IT BETTER BE DONE WITH
PUBLIC RESOURCES AND NOT WITH.
RULES THAT ARE BACKED BY PRIVATE
INVESTORS.
SO AS PART OF THE CONCERN THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD --
WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
INVOLVES STATE FUNDS TO YOUR THE
PLANET AND WE'D RATHER SEE THE
BUDGET THE PUBLIC BUDGET. FOR
FINANCIAL AID GROHL.
AT MAY BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR
FOLKS WHO WHO NEEDED. FOR A LOW
THIS IS NOT REPLACING
FINANCIALLY BUT IT'S IN ADDITION.
TO THIS WE GET WE'D LIKE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES TO THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS HERE MISTER
CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR OF I'M ALSO A
LITTLE BIT SURPRISED TO HEAR OR
OPPOSITION --
OPINION --
YOU --
INTERPRET THIS ONE AS SAW.
BURDEN OF FOR THE GRADUATE --
S. SELLECK A WAGE GARNISHMENT.
BUT YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT THE
MANY STUDENTS TO DO GRADUATE.
WITH THE TO SHOW AND THAT'S AND
THE MOST OF THEM DON'T CARRY
HIGH INTEREST.
AND THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME.
AFTER A CERTAIN --
NUMBER OF WHAT MINE SO FOR YEARS.
AND THEN ALSO --
THE INCOME BASED --
OUT A PAYMENT PLAN HAS TO BE
WORKED OUT THE HOW MUCH THE
PERSON CAN PAY AND ALL FOR WHAT
THE KERRIER.
SO THIS IS --
NOT --
MANDATING ANYBODY IT WOULD BE
MORE OF USING.
A PRIVATE FUND.
A COMPANY WILL INVEST.
ON A STUDENT --
BETTING IT.
IN A DOOR SO TAKING A RISK.
WHAT THE THE PERSON THAT WOULD
HAVE A WINNING POTENTIAL?
AND THE PUTTING MY MONEY IF I
WAS TO INVESTOR.
AND THEN --
OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD.
AND THE THAT THE SOUTHERN
PORTION WHATEVER COMFORTABLE.
UNDER THE AGREEMENT TOUGH I
INCOME SHARE THE AGREEMENT HOW
MUCH.
LIFE IT --
FEEL COMFORTABLE TO PAY BACK UP
A MONTH.
A COULD BE 5% COULD BE 10% WHICH
YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE.
SO THIS IS --
AND THE NEW. FOR STUDENTS --
TO FIND --
THE TUITION MECHANISM.
A COULD BE A GRANT COULD BE
[inaudible]
DEBT.
COULD BE OUR STATE THAT THE WHAT
FEDERAL DEBT THE WALL GROUP
COULD BE THAT PERSONAL DATA.
THIS ONE IS A UNIFORM IT IT IT
IT IS SAID THAT THE HOWEVER.
UP AN INVESTOR IS THE BEDDING ON
YOU HEY YOU IT YOU ARE COULD
THINK TO YOUR THEN I'M GONNA BAD
ON YOU.
AND STUDY HOT AND THE INVESTING
IN NEW SO I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
ALTERNATIVE.
SO -- THAT'S
MY IN A KINDA.
REFLECTIVE A COMMENT UP ON YOUR
QUESTION BUT I DO HAVE A SOME
QUESTION TO THE OR SO MAYBE --
AND ON WITNESS --
BUT DO UNIVERSITY YOU MENTIONED
THAT.
AND THE OTHER THAN PUT THROUGH.
WHAT ARE THE COLLEGES OR
UNIVERSITIES?
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROGRAM HOW LONG AND THE WHAT
THE SUCCESS RATE IS.
AND I'M GONNA NUMBER B	C
COMPANIES.
INVOLVED.
IS A ONE COMPANY IS TO A BETTING
ONE HUNDRED STUDENTS ALL HUNDRED
COMPANIES --
SUPPORTING HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AND THEN ALSO.
WHAT THE MAJORS --
FOR EXAMPLE ENGINEERS SO
COMPUTER SCIENCE SO MAY BE OF
MORE.
IN ALL.
THE PROMISING AND THE COMPANIES
TO MAKE --
ALL ON THE ENGINEERING SCIENCE --
NOT NOT A HUMANITIES SO SO
SOURCE THIS THERE IS A SUCH ARE
THE SO MY YOU KNOW.
IF YOU HAVE ANY SUCH SUCH A DATA
SURE AND THE MOST --
SECOND QUESTION IS --
WHAT IF WHAT IF THE STUDENT --
WAS NOT A GOOD BET AND THAT
DIDN'T [inaudible]
FINISH.
AND I COULDN'T GRADUATE AND MY
MONEY THAT I INVESTED.
WELL TWO YEARS SO WILL BE WASTED.
AND WHAT KIND OF A RESOURCE THAT
MEAN THAT REQUEST OF WHAT DO I
HAVE.
SO THOSE OF MY QUESTIONS IF YOU
CASH YOUR TO PRODUCE THE ONLY
MAJOR SYSTEM UNIVERSITY AND IN
PART DUE IS.
PART OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
INDIANA SYSTEM IT'S NOT A
PRIVATE INSTITUTION.
PRODUCERS SYSTEM DIRECTOR AND WE
IT TOOK A LONG TIME TO PUT RIVER
WORKING WITH PRETTY ON SITE FOR
ABOUT ELEVEN MONTHS.
SO IT IT'S NOT A FAST PROGRAM TO
STAND UP [inaudible]
ON PRODUCES A COUPLE THINGS
MITCH DANIELS IS THE PRESIDENT
PURDUE UNIVERSITY FORMER
GOVERNOR OF INDIANA.
SO A LOT OF THIS BOOK THE WAY
MITCH WANTED TO WORK.
THE PROGRAM AT PURDUE IS SET UP
SO THE LIGHT START WITH EXTEND
IT EXPECTATIONS OF INCOME.
AND THEN YOU ADJUST.
THE TIME OF THE OBLIGATION THE
PERCENTAGE TO GET ROUGHLY
SIMILAR RETURNS TO THE FOR DOING
DOWN THEY WERE THE ONES THAT
INITIALLY FUND.
THE FIRST YEAR OF A HUNDRED AND
FOR STUDENTS SIGNED UP.
SECOND YEAR I THINK THEY HAD A
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR AND THE LAST
NEWS I GOT THE OTHER DAYS ARE UP
TO SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY NOW.
SOUTH.
ON EXPLICITLY FOCUS NOT ON
TRYING TO REPLACE THE FEDERAL
STUDENT LOAN STAFFERS OR NON
THEY FOCUSED ON A LOT OF OUT OF
STATE STUDENTS AND PURDUE BLOW
THROUGH THEIR FEDERAL LIMóN.
THEY HAVE TO FIND ANOTHER SOURCE
FOR MONEY PRODUCER TO REPLACE
THE PARENT PLUS LOANS IN THE
PRIVATE LOANS FOR STUDENTS THAT
BLOW THROUGH THAT LIMóN.
SO THAT WAS THE IDEA PRODUCE.
TARGETED RETURN.
YOU COULD HAVE TO THINK OF
THERE'S LEVERAGE HERE YOU CAN
PLAY WITH THE STRUCTURE PRODUCED
TARGETED RETURN FOR THE WHOLE
POOL IS 9% BEFORE WRITE OFFS IN
ABOUT SEVEN POINT SIX AFTER
WRITE OFFS.
SO I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST SYSTEM SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
LOOKED AT THIS AND ARE LOOKING
AT THIS.
THERE IS A BUNCH OF SMALL
UNIVERSITIES OUT THERE WE'VE
SPOKEN TO THEM.
THE CITY UNIVERSITY SYSTEM NEW
YORK IS LOOKING AT THE STILL THE
BILL AGAIN FOR AWHILE.
THE STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN
NEW YORK IS LOOKING AT THEM --
THE TEXAS COMMON FUNDERS LOOKING
TO INVEST.
THE TEXAS UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IS
LOOKING UP.
AND THERE'S PROBABLY A BUNCH OF
OTHER CONVERSATIONS GOING ON
THEY TEND TO POP UP AND GO DOWN.
I'LL ALSO TELL YOU EXPLICITLY.
LOTS OF UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS LIKE
THE IDEA AS LONG AS THEY DON'T
HAVE TO FUND. TO THE PEARLY
HAVING SOMEONE ELSE FUNDS THAT.
BUT THERE DEVELOPMENT OFFICER
ISRAEL'S IS NOT INTERESTED IN
WRITING THE CHECK BECAUSE THEY
WANT.
TO WRITE CHECKS FOR OTHER THINGS
WE GET THAT PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED
PRETTY RISKY WAS FUNDED
INITIALLY BY THE ENDOWMENT.
AND THEN THE EXISTENTIALLY SOLD
DOWN SOME OF THEIR POSITION TO
TO CHARITIES BASED IN INDIA.
I'M NOT AWARE.
THE PRODUCES A TAKEN ANY.
I JUST ACTUALLY.
I'M NOT A NON DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENT.
HE WAS TAKING MONEY FROM TO
CORPORATIONS IN INDIANA THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN PARTICULAR CITY
AND THEY FUNDED AN EXPECTED RATE
OF RETURN.
IN SORT OF THE MID SINGLE DIGITS.
I GOT ALL I CAN SAY HERE TODAY.
ON THE REST OF THE COUNTRY IN
TERMS OF FUNDING AYE ESSAYS HAS
TYPICALLY FUNDED THEM OUT OF THE
MIX.
OF CHERNOBYL GRANTS AND LORENA
RETURNS THIS IS FOR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS. FOR PRIVATE
BOOT CAMPS FOR PROGRAMMING SORT
OF PROGRAMS.
THOSE RETURNS ARE TYPICALLY
LOOKED IN THE MID TO HIGH TEENS
NOT SORT OF ONE OF OUR ISSUES.
IS INVESTORS ARE LOOKING TO MAKE
14% PLUS. NINE WE THINK THAT'S
AN ISSUE THAT PROBABLY FEEL HE
GRAPPLE WITH THAT --
BUT ONLY FOR THE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS AND FOR THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN AROUND
A LONG TIME THEY'RE NOT FOR
PROFIT.
WE SEE TYPICALLY SEEN TARGET
AREAS TO RETURN FOR SIX OR 7%.
SO.
YES THERE'S NO INTEREST BUT BY
MOVING THOSE LEVERS ABOUT
EXPECTED INCOME WHAT'S THE
DURATION OF THE CONTRACT WHAT'S
THE PERCENTAGE OF INCOME YOU CAN
TARGET DIFFERENT RATES OF RETURN.
QUESTION.
IF I BUY INVESTED IN A STUDENTS
SPECIFICALLY AS OPPOSED TO A
POOL WHICH IS TYPICALLY WHAT
HAPPENS AND THAT STUDENT.
DROPPED OUT.
IF THEIR INCOME NEVER EXCEEDS
THE THRESHOLD YOU'RE GONNA MAKE
NOTHING.
IF THEY'RE EXCEEDING THREE
INCOME EXCEEDS THE THRESHOLD A
LITTLE BIT.
YOU MAY MAKE A LITTLE BIT ARE
YOU GONNA GET YOUR MONEY BACK.
DEPENDS ON WHAT THE ASSUMPTION
WAS THE LIKELY NOT.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SHIFT RISK FROM STUDENTS.
WHO MAY NOT STAND THERE MAJOR
WHO MAY NOT GET EMPLOYED WHOM
MAY HAVE TO GO HOME AND TAKE
CARE OF A PARENT?
WHO MAY HAVE TO MOVE BACK TO FOR
THE COUNTRY WITH THE INCOME IS
IN HIGH IS TO HAVE THAT RICHARD
REID RETURN THOSE PAYMENTS
AUTOMATICALLY ADJUST?
HAS THEIR INCOME ADJUST AND IF
THEY'RE OUT OF WORK.
IT TURNS OFF.
UNLIKE.
THE FEDERAL ID OUR PROGRAM WHICH
IS A NICE IDEA BUT HORRIBLY
MISTREATED UNLIKE PRIVATE LOANS
UNLIKE PARENT PLUS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A PERFECT
SOLUTION I JUST THINK IT CAN BE
CAN BE BETTER THAN ALL THE OTHER
ONES OUT THERE.
EDIT YOUR QUESTION.
YEP BUT THE IF.
THE HOW HOW LONG IT --
DID A DID TO PUT BUT TO BEGIN
THIS PROGRAM. FOUR YEARS AGO
FOUR YEARS FOUR YEARS AGO.
SO THERE AND THEY STARTED WITH
SENIORS WHO GRADUATED MIDDLE FOR
YEARS SO WILL BEGIN TO SEE THE
GRADUATES WELL SO THE
INTERESTING PART IS.
A FAIR NUMBER PRODUCES INITIAL
GROUP WENT ON TO GRADUATE SCHOOL.
SO THE AGREEMENT IS ESSENTIALLY
IN SUSPENDED ANIMATION WHICH OF
ONE OF OUR AMENDMENTS.
WHAT THE STUDENTS ARE IN
GRADUATE SCHOOL?
AND THEN IT STARTS ONCE THEY GET
WHICH ARE NO LONGER IN FULL TIME
SCHOOL.
WHICH THE FEDERAL ONE DOES THE
PRIVATE LOANS ARE LESS CONTROL
THAT WAY.
IT'S SORT OF EMBEDS A BUNCH OF
FLEXIBILITY.
CELL AND PRETTY COLORS SEVEN
SAID.
SO HOW IS THIS GOING TO AFFECT
OUR RETURN I SAID THE FACT THE
GREATER AND SO MUCH MORE AFTER
THEY GET THEIR GRADUATE DEGREE.
YOU'LL PROBABLY DO BETTER SO IT
WOULD BE ON A BIT TOO EARLY TO
SEE THE WHETHER IT AND THERE'S
NO NEED A DATE OF WERE AVAILABLE
AND AND PRODUCED PROGRAM.
IF YOU'RE IN ONE OF THE STEM
FIELDS OF YOUR COMPUTER
PROGRAMMING MAJOR JUST FOR
EXAMPLE PRODUCE.
THE OBLIGATION EXTENDS FOR
EIGHTY FOUR MONTHS.
AND IT'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE IF
YOU'RE IN THEIR LOWEST EARNING
MAJOR JUST FORESTRY.
IT'S A HUNDRED FOURTEEN MONTHS
AND IT'S PLEASE LIKE SEVEN POINT
6%.
WE ADVISE FOR YOU NOT TO DO THAT
WE SAID ONE DOES HAVE ONE
PROGRAM FOR THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
AND THIS GUY NAY MITCH DANIELS
SAID NOW OUR TRYING TO SEND A
STRONGER SIGNAL ABOUT WHAT YOU
TO MAJOR IN.
WE CAN ARGUE ABOUT THAT THERE'S
LOTS OF WAYS TO DO IT --
MR GABRIEL THANK YOU THINK THINK
THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ME FOR THIS MEASURE I
THINK IT'S ALWAYS WORTH.
THINKING ABOUT NEW --
STRATEGIES FOR EDUCATION FINANCE
AND OPENING UP THE DOORS OF OF
COLLEGE MORE FOLKS.
I'M A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED ABOUT
THIS -- IN
IN MAYBE NOT TRADE UNDERSTAND IT
I THINK WITH A LOT OF THESE
THINGS THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS HERE.
I'M SORRY THESE PERCENTAGES
CALCULATORS ICING THERE SOME
FINANCIAL MODELING ACTUARIES ARE
INVOLVED IN SO I GUESS MY
QUESTIONS THERE ARE.
IF THAT MODELING IS OFFICE WE'VE
SEEN YOU KNOW FOLKS INSTRUCTION
FINANCE CAN BE AWFULLY SO THAT A
LITTLE BIT DURING THE THE LAST --
GREAT RECESSION --
IS THE TAXPAYER ON THE HOOK FOR
THAT OR THE UNIVERSITY AND THE
SECOND QUESTION IS THIS GOING TO
CREATE.
INCENTIVES FOR UNIVERSITIES TO
STEER STUDENTS INTO CERTAIN
PROFESSIONS MAYBE AWAY WILL AWAY
FROM THINGS LIKE THE PEACE CORPS
IN TOWARDS THINGS LIKE
INVESTMENT BANKING SO.
THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT CAME TO MIND FOR ME.
SOBERING TRY TO UNDO THE REVERSE
ORDER TO THE FROM MY BRAIN WORKS.
SO IN PART OF THE IN TERMS OF
THE PEACE CORPS IN TERMS OF
RELIGIOUS WORK IN TERMS OTHER
STUFF LIKE THAT.
THE I. SA IS TIED INCOME IF
THEY'RE NOT MAKING INCOME
THERE'S ACTUALLY BURNING OFF
YEARS OBLIGATION.
DEPENDING ON HOW THE CONTRACTS
WRITTEN SO ACTUALLY. ONE OF
PURDUE'S CONCERNS ON THE IN
DOWNSIDE WAS THAT MORE STUDENTS
WHEN IN FACT ELECTED JOINING THE
PEACE CORPS.
FOREGO WORK IN RELIGIOUS
PROGRAMS AND THAT ACTUALLY WENT
UP SO ACTUALLY GETS BETTER
FLEXIBILITY FOR DOING.
PUBLIC WORK WE IT GETS BETTER
FLEXIBILITY FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING AM DES WHO WANT TO GO
WORK IN.
THIRD WORLD COUNTRY IT MEDIA LEE
CLICK ST AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT YOUR STUDENT LOAN
ACCRUING COME BACK.
IT BURNS OFTEN PRODUCE ACHES THE
HIT.
THE TAXPAYERS ARE ON THE HOOK
THE MINI SHOWS UP DAY ONE FROM
THE FUNDING SOURCE THE ENDOWMENT
THE FIVE ONE TWO THREES OR THE
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE WILLING TO
EMBARK.
ON THAT PROGRAM SO TAXPAYERS
NEVER ON THE HOOK FOR THAT SORT
OF THING WHICH IS TO BE A HUGE
FEATURE --
WAS THE OTHER QUESTION I MEAN I
I GUESS JUST ON THE PART ABOUT
THE TAX FOR NEVER BEING ON THE
HOOK ME WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DOING THIS A PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT
SO.
IF IF THE FINANCIAL MODELING IS
OFF AND THE IN DOWNEY THE
UNIVERSITY ENDS UP TAKING AHEAD
I MEAN THAT'S GOING TO BE TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THE PUBLIC AND IF
FOR WORKING WITH A CORPORATION
IT ASSUMES THAT THAT CORPORATION
THAT'S WORKING WITH UNIVERSITIES
ADEQUATELY FUNDED BY FLETCHER
SAY THAT.
THE BECAUSE THE MONEY SHOWS UP
DAY.
ONE SO IF SO AS LONG AS THE
CHECK SHOWS UP YOUR FREEDOM CARE
ABOUT THE CREDIT WORTHINESS OF
THE PEOPLE GAVE YOU THE CHECK
BECAUSE YOU GOT THE CHECK.
AND YOU PAY THE TUITION TO THE
UC OR CSU.
SO SO THAT KIDS THE CREDIT
BURDEN.
ONCE YOU CASH THE CHECK YOU'RE
NOT WORRIED ABOUT THEIR CREDIT
WORTHINESS TO THE EXTENT THAT IS
FROM THE ENDOWMENT OF YOU SEE OR
CSU YEAH YOUR BUT THE WEIRD PART
ABOUT AYE ESSAYS.
MUCH MORE THAN DEBT.
WHICH IS SORT OF THIS IS THAT
BOBBY REPROOF IF YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT A DEBT CONTRACT LOOKS LIKE.
YOUR BEST TODAY WITH A DEAD
INVESTORS THE DAY YOU BOOK IT.
AND THEN WITH YOUR BUNCH OF
PEOPLE THAT DO YOU LONG TO
MONITOR THINGS DON'T PERFORM IT
SLOWLY GOES SOUTH.
WITH AN AYE A SAY YEAH YOU HAVE
SOME THE GO SOUTH.
AND USE ON THE GO NORTH.
AND SO THE VARIANCE ON A BIG
POOL OF I SAY CONTRACTS LIKE IF
WE GET EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA.
IT DOESN'T MOVE MUCH AT ALL EVEN
IN THE GREAT RECESSION WE WENT
THROUGH LOOKING AT LOW INCOME
LOW WELL STUDENTS.
HISPANICS TWENTY FIVE YOU KNOW
THAT SORT OF DATA.
THEIR TOTAL INCOME OF THAT LOW
INCOME GROUP IN THE GREAT
RECESSION DROP 6% FOR TWO YEARS
AND THEN CAME BACK.
IT IS BACK TO WHERE WE EXPECTED.
YOU KNOW SO THE RISK WITH A FULL
RSA'S IS MUCH BETTER THAN WITH A
FULL OF LOOKS.
AND THE POINT IS STUDENTS TO
MAKE MORE WILL PAY MORE.
AND FOR LOTS OF MIDDLE CLASS
STUDENTS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO MAKE THAT BET
THEY KNOW THEY'RE GONNA MAKE A
TON OF MONEY.
THEY DON'T NEED THE RESTRAINTS
REALIZE SAY THEY'RE FINE.
WE FOCUSED ON FOR STUDENTS LOW
INCOME LOW WEALTH FIRST
GENERATION.
THEY GET WHAT FINANCIAL RISK YES
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH.
PLEASE SEE.
AND FOR THEM A WELL STRUCTURED
ONE I KEEP PUTTING ADDING TIME
WHICH REMEMBER THAT.
DOES DO RESTAURANTS FOR DOES
GIVE MORE FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED.
I'VE GONE TOO LONG START.
YEAH I JUST I THANK YOU FOR THAT
I I I APPRECIATE THAT --
YOU KNOW I GUESS I'M STILL
WORKING MY MIND AROUND AROUND
SOME OF THE STUFF AND AND I'D
WANT ONE JUST FINAL QUESTION
THEN I MAKE A COMMENT WHICH IS.
SO IS THIS IS THE LEGISLATION IS
WRITTEN NOW CONTEMPLATING THAT
THE CSU WHEN YOU SEE WOULD ENTER
INTO CONTRACTS WITH PRIVATE
ENTITIES. FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
ENTITIES THAT WOULD OPERATE
THESE AYE SAYS I DON'T THINK SO.
OKAY SO IT'S BUILT SPECIFICALLY
BE GEARED TOWARDS FIVE OH ONE C.
THREES NOW IN THE CURRENT
LEGISLATION BASICALLY SAYS THE
STATE'S GOING TO FUND THE PILOT
AS I READ.
WELCOME TO H. ONE PILOT AT ONE
SEE ISSUE AND WHEN YOU SEE RIGHT
OKAY.
SO BUT SO SO THAT INITIAL AGAIN
SO THAT MONEY THAT'S COMING IN
FROM BUT THAT'S MONEY THAT THE
TAXPAYERS ARE TO BE ON THE HOOK.
FOR ABSOLUTE OKAY SO I I
APPRECIATE SOMETHING TO THIS --
I'M IN A VOTE FOR TODAY
COMMITTEE BUT I'M IN A RESERVE
MY VOTE ON THE FLOOR WHEN I
UNDERSTAND THIS CONCEPT OF A
BETTER.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR WELL.
AND MAYBE I DIDN'T HEAR
CORRECTLY YOU SAID THERE'S NO
INTEREST CHARGED ON THESE LOANS.
SO CAN YOU TO DIRECTLY AND SORRY.
THESE LOANS ARE NOT LO THESE
FINANCINGS AS OPPOSED TO DOING
PRINTS ONE INTEREST.
YOU HAVE A DEAL THE LOOKS MORE
LIKE A VENTURE CAPITALIST.
FUNDING A START UP YOU SAY.
YOU'RE GONNA GO GET AN EDUCATION.
AND REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU DO
WHEN YOU COME OUT THE DOOR SIX
MONTHS LATER YOU'RE GONNA PAY ME
AFFECTS PERCENT OF YOUR INCOME
FOR A FIXED PERIOD OF TIME.
AND IF IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO PAY ME
BACK.
THAT'S MY PROBLEM AND IF IT'S
MORE I GET MORE UP TO THE CAP.
WHICH OF THE CAP THE SYMBOLIC
ASIAN STOCKS SO IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT THING THAT ALONE.
RIGHT IT'S DIFFERENT BUT IT'S
JUST STILL PROBABLY PAYING MORE
THAN YOU GET BUT THAT THAT
TRANSLATES INTO INTERESTED IN MY
THINKING TO TRANSLATE INTO A
CONTINUED OBLIGATION ABSOLUTE
OKAY SO SO AND AND THIS IS TO BE
FUN BY THE SEE ISSUES IN AT AND
NOT.
PRIVATE ENTITIES OF SOMETHING OF
THAT NATURE IS THAT INITIALLY.
THE PILOT IS FUNDED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA OKAY IF IT IF THE
AFTER THE PILOT ENDS WHAT'S THE
WHAT IS THE GOAL BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS UP HERE EVERY PILOT
BECOMES.
A A PROGRAM. FOR LIFE.
AND SO.
WHAT WE LEARN ANYTHING FROM IT
OR NOT?
GOES INTO A PERMANENT STATUS SO.
I THINK.
THERE'S A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
WHEN WE HAVE GONE AROUND THE
COUNTRY FOR YOU DIDN'T
ACCIDENTALLY GET MONEY FROM FIVE
OH ONE C.?
THREE THEY ARE INTERESTED IN
MORE STUDENTS GRADUATING
COMPLETING COLLEGE GOING.
FOR SO THAT WAS AN ACCIDENT ARE
YOU COULD SEE THAT HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU COULD SEE THE STATE GOING
FORWARD OFFERING YOU CAN SEE
CORPORATION SHOT BECAUSE HE SAW
CAN VALLEY SAYING.
WE NEED MORE PROGRAM WHICH WILL
FUND WE'LL SET OUR COST OF
CAPITAL REALLY LOW. TO BE FAIR
WITH SILICON VALLEY GETS AS WELL
FOR YOU WORKERS OF THEY DON'T
HAVE TO TRY THERE'S LOTS OF WAYS
OF PLAYING THE SAYS HIS
COMPLEXES IS.
I GET A COMPLEX TO YOUR POINT.
AND SOMETIMES MADE A MISTAKE
THIS IS COMPLEX AND TAKE SOME
SERIOUS THOUGHT TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT YOUR BILL. FOR THAT FAIR
[inaudible]
I GUESS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE --
SEE NONE MR VOEPEL IF YOU'D LIKE
TO GIVE YOUR CLOTHES YES SIR.
ONCE AGAIN ITS PILOT PROGRAM.
FUNDED FOR SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
AND IT'S FOR A TWO YEAR PERIOD
AND THEN WE'LL BE LOOKING AT IT
VERY CLOSELY ACTUALLY YOU WILL
BE LOOKING AT VERY CLOSELY TO
SEE HOW.
WELL IT PERFORMED --
ONE OTHER THING ABOUT AND PLOY
YEARS IS.
I ANTICIPATE CORPORATIONS
FUNDING THIS IN THE FUTURE ALSO
WHEN THESE KIDS GET A JOB IN
SILICON VALLEY OR WHEREVER.
THE EMPLOYERS CAN PAY IT OFF.
NOT BAD IT CAN BE AN EMPLOYEE
BENEFIT ON TOP OF EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT THIS CAN BE GOOD ABOUT --
LAST YEAR THIS PAST ALMOST
UNANIMOUSLY IN THE ASSEMBLY
THERE WAS ONLY ONE NO VOTE.
AND I NOT QUITE SURE WHAT THAT
WAS IT DID FAIL IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE SENATE.
AND I WILL PROMISE YOU THAT I
WILL BE WORKING VERY HARD.
I MEAN IF I HAVE TO PROMISE TO
PULL WEEDS IN THE FRONT YARD
I'LL BE WORKING WITH THEM OKAY
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU AND AND I JUST WANT TO
CORRECT ONE THING TO THE
AUTHORED THAT THERE IS NO MONEY
YET ALLOCATED IN THIS BILL.
THERE IS NO DOLLAR AMOUNT.
IT WILL GO TO PROBES.
BUT I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE THIS BILL
FORWARD I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WISDOM TO GO --
TO PURDUE UNIVERSITY WHERE I
ATTENDED I MIGHT HAVE A HAD THIS
PROGRAM EXISTED I MIGHT HAVE
GRADUATED FROM PURDUE UNIVERSITY.
INSTEAD OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT RIVERSIDE.
WHERE I WAS A IN STATE?
THE RESIDENT AND PAID IN STATE
TUITION AS OPPOSED TO OUT OF
STATE IN INDIANA [inaudible]
AND AND I VOTED FOR THIS BILL
LAST YEAR HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
AGAIN I THINK WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT THINGS --
THAT WE HEAR OF OUR STUDENTS
LEAVING COLLEGE WITH THE STUDENT
DEBT THIS IS A AN IDEA THAT'S
WORTH LOOKING INTO SO AGAIN
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR.
OF WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER
LOWE AS SECOND BY MR GABRIEL --
IF BUT I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA ALL RIGHT MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I MURATSUCHI --
TO GI BLOOM.
ROOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY.
DALY I KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER HI. ELEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHAT WHAT WILL MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BUT ISLI MONGO
AHEAD AND PLEASE COME FORWARD?
BUT WILL GO TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
SEC.
THERE ARE NO BILLS OKAY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AGE ARE --
TO MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I BIRD SU CHI.
SU CHI I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY.
DALY I KILEY.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I MY APOLOGIES TO THE
COMMITTEE.
WE DID NOT HAVE A MOTION.
I I KNOW THE OF THE MOTION BY
MISTER LEVINE.
SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER.
I'M AFRAID WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
CALL THE ROLL AGAIN.
THE MOTION IS.%
AND WE CAN WE DO THAT.
JUST REPLACE THE ROLE.
NOW CAN DO THAT OKAY WILL WILL
CALL THE ROLL OKAY MOTIONS BE
ADOPTED TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I ARAMBULA I MEAN
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY.
DALY I KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON EYES SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I'D. ELEVEN ZERO THE
CONTENT CALENDARS PAST WE'VE
BEEN OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
WE ARE NOW ON FILE ITEM.
TEN ACR THIRTY ONE WELCOME IS
LIVE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
BUT I CAN'T GREAT THANK YOU AND
WITH ME I HAVE DAYS IN HIS ALSO
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCES OFFICE
AND HE SAID NOW THAT IT THEY
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA.
TIRMIDHI NONMEMBERS COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL MAKE THIS QUICK FOR
YOU -- THIS
RESOLUTION SEEKS TO DO THREE
DIFFERENT THINGS THE FIRST IS TO
RECOGNIZE THE CAN'T
CONTRIBUTIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. TO CELEBRATE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND TO ENCOURAGE
CALIFORNIANS TO VISIT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DURING THE
MONTH OF APRIL I ALSO WANT TO
THANK OUR BOARD OF GOVERNORS WHO
ARE IN THIS ROOM. FOR THEIR
ADVOCACY DAY TODAY.
LIKE TWICE AND LOOKED AT IT WITH
ME COLLEGE LEAGUE --
WE THINK CALIFORNIA CAN COLLEGES
ARE AN INDISPENSABLE INVESTMENT
IN OUR PRESENT AND FUTURE
PROSPERITY.
SO -- ACR
THIRTY ONE PROVIDES SELECT AND
CELEBRATE OUR CALIFORNIA ME
COLLEGES SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
DO THAT --
AND I APPRECIATE THE STUDENTS AT
THAT HAVE COME THROUGH AND ARE
GOING THROUGH OUR SYSTEM AND
THEIR FUTURE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY WHAT OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OF IT'S LEóN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I WITH THE THE SUPPORT AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CANCERS OFFICE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS THAT ARE IN THE ROOM.
HERE WITH US I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NAY BUT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
A BY MISTER LOWE.
SECOND BY MISTER GABRIEL AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY BEFORE WE
CALL THE ROLL AS A LONG TIME.
TRUSTEE AT RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE I WHERE I SERVED FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS VERY HAPPY TO BE.
IN SUPPORT OF RIVERS --
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MONTH --
AND AND THIS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU SO MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEDINA MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY.
DALY I KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON PATTERSON I
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I'D. ELEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN --
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND NEXT SIDE OF ITEM NUMBER
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE MISS
ADVANTIS A. B. [inaudible]
FOR SIXTY THREE WELCOME
.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ON ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIX THREE TODAY.
I TODAY PART TIME FACULTY MAKE
UP THE MAJORITY OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTRUCTORS NATIONWIDE
SPECIFICALLY RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED TO THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND ADJUNCT FACULTY
COMPARED.
TO NINETEEN THOUSAND FULL TIME
INSTRUCTORS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE BECOME INCREASINGLY RELIANT
UPON PART TIME I CHEN FACULTY
WHO OFTEN ARE PAID LOW A FEW
BENEFITS AND MINIMAL JOB
SECURITY.
PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY ARE THE MOST IMPACTED BY
REQUIREMENTS TO HOLD ADVANCED
DEGREES AS A RESULT BEAR HEAVY
STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
MOREOVER MANY ADJUNCT FACULTY
MUST WORK THE EQUIVALENT OF FULL
TIME HOURS BUT AT MULTIPLE
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAS LED TO
REGULATORY SILOS THAT HINDER THE
ABILITY OF I CHEN FACULTY TO
BENEFIT.
FROM THE FEDERAL PUBLIC SERVICE
LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAM AB FOUR
SIX THREE ATTEMPTS TO ELIMINATE
THE BUREAUCRATIC RED TAPE THAT
LIMITS THE OPPORTUNITY A PART
TIME ADJUNCT FACULTY FROM
APPLYING TO THIS FEDERAL STUDENT
LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAM.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE COMMUNITY
CALL WITH THREE POINT THREE FIVE
HOURS WORKED FOR EACH HOUR OF
LECTURE OR CLASSROOM TIME MAKING
IT EASIER FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PART TIME FACULTY MEMBERS TO
QUALIFY FOR THIS FEDERAL STUDENT
LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAM.
AB FOUR SIX THREE SIX TO ENSURE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE PUBLIC
SERVICE OF PART TIME FACULTY BY
ALLOWING THEM TO HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAM
THAT IS BENEFITS.
THAT ACTUALLY IS AVAILABLE TO
FULL TIME FACULTY.
PASSING A BEFORE IT SIX THREE IS
IMPERATIVE TO HELP BEING ARE
PART TIME FACULTY I BELIEVE IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE ASSIST
EDUCATORS WHO DEDICATE THEIR
LIVES TO THEIR STUDENTS EACH AND
EVERY DAY WE'RE GIVING THEM A
FIGHTING CHANCE TO SIMPLY APPLY
TO THIS FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN
PROGRAM.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
VALERIE NESBITT A PART TIME
FACULTY --
INSTRUCTOR AT SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
PALOMAR COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS
WELL AS ANDREAS LATER A PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INSTRUCTOR AT LANEY COLLEGE AND
BERKELEY CITY COLLEGE
[inaudible]
HI -- A GOOD
AFTERNOON WHICH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS VALERIE NESBITT AND I'M A
PART TIME FACULTY MEMBER
TEACHING AT TWO DIFFERENT
COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND PALOMAR DISTRICT --
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AB --
FOR SIXTY THREE LET ME TELL YOU
A LITTLE ABOUT MYSELF HOME.
IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND HOW I GOT
THESE LOANS --
WHEN I WAS FIFTEEN I LEFT MY
HOUSE?
DUE TO ABUSE --
I WAS REALLY GIVEN THE CHOICE OF
STREETS OR SCHOOL HOME AND
SCHOOL WITH MY SAFE ZONE SO
THAT'S WHERE I WENT AND I STAYED --
I LOVE SCHOOL AND BUT MY PARENTS
MADE TOO MUCH MONEY.
THEY WEREN'T PAYING FOR MY
SCHOOL OBVIOUSLY BUT THEY WERE
TARA THAT BUT THEY MADE TOO MUCH
MONEY SO I DIDN'T QUALIFY FOR
ANY --
STUDENT LOAN --
ANY SORT OF GRANTS OR ANY OF
THAT.
SO MY ONLY OPTION REALLY TO GET
THROUGH SCHOOL WAS STUDENT LOANS --
CURRENTLY AT THIS POINT I HAVE A
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
STUDENT LOANS.
AND IT THIS BALANCE HAVE GOTTEN
BIGGER OVER TIME --
BECAUSE THERE WERE TIMES WHEN I
WAS UNABLE TO PAY IT.
AND SO I HAD FORBEARANCE WHICH
ADDS UP THE LOAN PAYMENTS --
AT THIS POINT MY STUDENT LOAN
PAYMENTS --
EXCEED.
SLIGHTLY EXCEED MY MORTGAGE
PAYMENTS AND WHEN I SAY MY
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS ACTUALLY MY
WIFE'S MORTGAGE PAYMENTS --
I WAS NOT ABLE TO BE PUT ON THE
LOAN BECAUSE I CANNOT AFFORD ART
BECAUSE OF MY CREDIT BECAUSE OF
THE HUGE STUDENT LOAN DEBT --
AT THIS POINT THERE'S I I AM
FIFTY FOUR YEARS OLD AND THERE'S
JUST NOT A CHANCE I'M GONNA BE
ABLE TO PAY THIS OFF.
ABSENT HELP --
I HAVE LOST A LOT OF SLEEP OVER
THIS ISSUE AND THEY'RE JUST
THERE IT'S IT'S IT'S
OVERWHELMING.
I I DRIVE AN EIGHT YEAR OLD CAR.
I WORKTWO JOBS IN ORDER TO JUST
A PORT BY STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS --
I DID APPROACH THE SCENE LONG
COMPANIES --
AND WAS TOLD I DID NOT QUALIFY
BECAUSE OF I WAS PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBER.
RIGHT NOW I I AM TEACHING AND
80% LOAD IN COLLEGE AND ONE AT
ANOTHER --
SO THIS PASSAGE OF THIS BILL IS
CRITICAL TO MY PERSONAL --
LIFE -- HOME
MY PROFESSIONAL AND FINANCIAL
FUTURE ON IT IS IT IS BECOME OF
AN IMPERATIVE --
SO I WHILE I AM TEACHING.
OVER THE LAST HAVE --
60% ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT --
AND THEN ANOTHER CLASS AT
ANOTHER --
ONE BUT IN --
ICE I AM PAID JUST FOR THE HOURS
THAT I SIT IN THAT CLASSROOM
TEACHING HOME I AM NOT PAID. FOR
I I AM PAID --
SOME OFFICE HOURS NOT AT THE
STANDARD RATE BUT IT WILL YOU
KNOW THAT --
AND I DO NOT GET PAID FOR
GRADING I DO NOT GET PAID FOR
PREP TIME FOR FOR TEXTBOOKS ANY
OF THAT --
SO THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT IS
DONE BECAUSE I LOVE IT --
AT LOVE THIS JOB IT'S THE BUT I
COULD USE SOME HELP IN PAYING
FOR MY STUDENT LOAN SO --
PASSING THIS WOULD REALLY HELP
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANDREA SLATER AND I WOULD LIKE
TO EXTEND MY THANKS --
ON BEHALF OF THE PART TIME
FACULTY THROUGH THE STATE FOR
YOUR TIME.
AND ASKING TO SUPPORT THE
PASSAGE OF AB.
FOR SIXTY THREE I'M IN MY SECOND
YEAR TEACHING AND THE PROUD TO
COMMUNICATE WHAT SYSTEM AND MY
VALLEY I LOVE MY JOB --
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN I BECAME THE
PRIMARY EARNER FOR MY HOUSEHOLD
AFTER MY PARTNER FACE DISABILITY
DUE TO A CHRONIC ILLNESS.
AND RIGHT NOW I HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOANS AN
INTEREST LARGELY DUE TO MY
DEMANDING GRADUATE SCHOOL
PROGRAM.
THAT ALLOWS ME TO TEACH.
THAT MADE IT BASICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO EVEN WORK
PART TIME DURING THE ACADEMIC
YEAR.
I TEACH THE MAXIMUM LOAD OF
THREE CLASSES AND BRING HOME
LESS THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH WITHOUT HEALTH
INSURANCE BENEFITS.
WHEN I HAD HEALTH INSURANCE LAST
SEMESTER THROUGH THE DISTRICT MY
TAKE HOME PAY WAS REDUCED TO
LESS THAN FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH?
I WORK HARD FOR MY STUDENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE TEN HOURS THAT I
AM PAID FOR I SPENT
APPROXIMATELY ANOTHER THIRTY
HOURS EACH WEEK WORKING WITH THE
STUDENTS GRADING PAPERS AND
UPDATING THE CLASS LECTURE
INFORMATION TO KEEP THE MATERIAL
RELEVANT AND ENGAGING FOR MY
STUDENTS.
THIS IS NOT UNUSUAL FOR MANY OF
US WHO DESPITE OUR TITLES ARE
REGULARLY DEVOTING MORE THAN
THIRTY FIVE HOURS A WEEK TO OUR
FACULTY POSITIONS IN ORDER TO
PRIORITIZE TEACHING.
OTHER FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT AND
THE NONPROFIT ARENA THAT WILL
PROVIDE A PATHWAY FOR LOAN
FORGIVENESS IS EXTREMELY LIMITED.
HEY MY STUDENT LOANS HAS BECOME
A BALANCING ACT AS MY OUTSIDE
CONSULTING WORK IS OFTEN
REQUIRED TO COVER BASIC LIVING
EXPENSES AND DEVOURED BY MONTHLY
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS.
INCREASING LEVELS OF STRESS AND
ANXIETY YOUR SUPPORT OF AB FOR
SIXTY THREE WILL GIVE US AS PART
TIME FACULTY SOME RELIEF AS
STUDENT LOANS ARE INCREASINGLY
NOT ONLY HAMPERING OUR ABILITY
TO ACHIEVE ECONOMIC.
SECURITY BUT ALSO PREVENT MANY
FROM ACHIEVING LIFE AFFIRMING
BENCHMARK SUCH AS STARTING A
FAMILY BUYING A HOME OR EVEN
PURCHASING A CAR DO THE HIGH
DEBT TO INCOME RATIO.
THAT THE BURDEN OF STUDENT LOANS
CRATES FRANCE WILL WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO STAY ACTIVE IN OUR
POSITIONS.
AND I VOTE ON AB FOR SIXTY THREE
TELLS US PART TIME FACULTY THAT
WE ARE VALUED FOR CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THIS
TIME.
AND I VOTE ON AB FOR SIXTY THREE
WILL HELP GIVE US PART TIME
FACULTY A CRITICAL STEP TOWARDS
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY FOR
ECONOMIC SURVIVAL. FOR ME AS AN
INDIVIDUAL YOUR AYE VOTE WILL
HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
STRESS I FACE TRYING TO REMAIN
COMMITTED TO THE CLASSROOM WHILE
MEETING MY FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THAT COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND GIVE THEIR NAME
IN THE GROUP THAT THEY REPRESENT.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE RON ROUTE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB FOUR SIX
THREE THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW ON BEHALF
OF LOS RIOS CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WHO ARE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SHOPKEEPERS ANOTHER
PROP THE FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER TWEENER.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN AT THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OUR BOARD IS
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL STANCE ON
THIS YET BUT WE AT IS GENERALLY
SUPPORT THE SPIRIT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
YES PLEASE MR BETTER THANK YOU I
A FIRST OF ALL I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT HERE. ONE CONCERN I HAVE
IS IF THE APPLICATION IS IN SOME
WAY -- BUT
NOT REFLECTIVE OF ACTUAL HOURS
WORKED.
COULD THIS COME BACK. TO BITE
THE APPLICANTS.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT HOW.
IS THERE A FORMULA HERE THAT
SAYS.
YOU WORK SO MANY HOURS OR IS
THIS A REFLECTION OF A TIME CARD
OR SOME KIND OF DEMONSTRATION.
THAT THE WORK WAS ACTUALLY
PERFORMED.
OR IS IT AN ASSUMPTION THAT THE
WORK IS BEING PERFORMED
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MISTER CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
GIVE PART TIME FACULTY.
A SHOT AT QUALIFYING FOR THE
FEDERAL.
PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM WHAT WE DID IS WE
DEVELOPED A MULTIPLIER OF THREE
POINT THREE FIVE WHICH WOULD BE
APPLIED TO THE NUMBER OF HOURS
THAT THEY TEACH --
AS AS VALERIE MENTIONED --
PART TIME FACULTY GENERAL CREDIT
FOR PLANNING TIME GRADING TIME
OFFICE HOURS LIKE CETERA AND SO
WITH THIS MULTIPLIER DOES IS
GIVE SOMEONE WHO TEACHES NINE
HOURS OR A POTENTIALLY THREE
CLASSES --
ANOTHER CREDIT TO GET TO THIRTY
HOURS WHICH THE FEDS REQUIRE TO
QUALIFY FOR THE LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM --
DAY IT STATES ARE.
ARE ALLOWED TO DETERMINE HOW
THOSE HOURS ARE ARE --
ARE CALCULATED AND SO THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE MODEL IT MIGHT GET ME
OUT OF IT DID YOU DON'T.
HAVE A CONCERN THAT.
SEVERAL YEARS FROM NOW.
THE FEDS MAY LOOK AT THIS AND
DISQUALIFY.
I DON'T AT THIS TIME NOW I DON'T --
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ON THIS LEGISLATION --
THERE ARE NUMBER OF STATES
CONSIDERING SIMILAR LEGISLATION --
I THINK WE'RE VERY CONFIDENT
THAT -- THIS
BILL WILL HELP --
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBERS ACTUALLY
QUALIFY FOR THIS LOAN
FORGIVENESS.
I I WANT TO SUPPORT THIS I WILL.
I DID NEED TO ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS I DO HAVE IN THE BACK
OF MY MIND A BIT OF A CONCERN.
ABOUT FORMULA.
AND HOW THAT WOULD BE VIEWED BY
THE FEDS.
BUT THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING THIS
BILL.
I'M ASSUMING UNDERSTAND.
SOME WHAT THE RISK OF THAT KIND
OF FORMULA MAY BE AND ARE
WILLING TO ACCEPT IT --
CONSIGNMENT CAN SEND ABOUT IT
BUT I WANNA I WANNA MOVE IT
FORWARD -- I
HAVE GREAT SYMPATHY FOR THE FOR
PART TIMERS AT AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES I I HOPE.
THAT MY CONCERN IS NOT WELL
FOUNDED.
THE ANSWER AND I DO WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT AS WELL AND JUST
EMPHASIZE SIDE SO --
UNDER FEDERAL REGULATION STATES
CAN DEFINE WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
FULL TIME EMPLOYEE I AND SO
THAT'S WHAT AB SIX FOUR SIX
THREE DOES TODAY IT DEFINES WHAT
THAT MEANS IN ORDER FOR A PART
TIME FACULTY.
ARE IN ORDER FOR THEM JUST TO
SIMPLY BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
PROGRAM I AND APPLY TO IN JUST
GIVE THEM A FIGHTING CHANCE TO
GET THROUGH THAT I'M IN ORDER.
TO RECEIVE SOME KIND OF STUDENT
LOAN DEBT FORGIVENESS SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME --
AND THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU OPPOSED AS WELL I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY TO SHOW OF PART TIME
FACULTY THAT THEY ARE VALUED.
THEY MISTER CHOI HAD A QUESTION
OR A COMMENT.
YES I A WAS SORE SO --
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POINT --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON HAS
RAISED THE MY CONSULTANT AND A
STAFF BOAT RACE THE SAME.
A CONCERN THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT --
THE FACT MEMBERS ARE LATER --
AND THAT THE IT MAY BECOME A THE
A BURDEN SO RATHER THAN.
TAKING A CHAS.
AND THEN ALSO.
I'M A BIT CONFUSED ABOUT THE
TESTIFIED.
NATIONWIDE A QUOTE THAT EACH
STATE.
HAS THE RIGHT TO DETERMINE SUCH
A FORMULA --
SO THAT MEANS --
HOW?
SO IF YOU JUST TO SIMPLY SUGGEST
THAT ONE NOW WHAT THE COURSE OF
THREE POINT THREE FIVE HOURS.
OUT WITH THAT EXCEPT WHAT --
THIS BODY.
PASSING THIS ROLE WE'RE
CERTIFIED.
THAT -- PART
TIME WORKERS ONE OUR TEACHING IS
EQUIVALENT TO THREE POINT THREE
FIVE HOURS.
AS A FULL MORE --
ADJUNCT FACULTY TIME. FOR ABOUT
THE EIGHTEEN YEARS --
SO I SYMPATHIZE.
HOW VALUABLE TIME WE PUT IN?
AT ALL I DIDN'T TEACH IT TO MAKE
MONEY -- BUT
THE MANY PEOPLE LIKE WE HEAR.
US SOME --
SOME TO RELY UPON --
THE INCOME AND TO GET QUALIFIED
TO TEACH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THEY HAVE WAS SUCH A HIGHS
CHILDREN THAT.
AND JUST OF LIKE FIFTY DOLLARS
IS SIX SIXTY DOLLARS AN HOUR IS
NOT GONNA.
IT'LL RAISE UP A HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE KIND OF DEPTH THE SO I THINK
THAT THIS IS SO.
A MEANS OF ATTRACTING GOOD ADAM
FACULTY MEMBERS ARE IF WE HAVE A
DISCOUNT PROGRAM I'M SURE MORE
QUALIFIED PEOPLE.
ARE WILL APPLY IN THE WHOLE.
THAT THAT THEY CAN GET THE A
WAIVER OF THE STERN LOANS --
SO THAT SOMEONE A RECRUITMENT
SIDE THE POSITIVE UP BUT THE
CURRENTLY STRUGGLING FACULTY
MEMBER SO WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS.
THE ONLY QUESTION THAT THE
ISSUES HAVE STATED THAT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE IS SO
SURE.
THAT THE CALIFORNIA SO FORMULA
THAT THE WE ARE.
CONSIDERING WHICH NOW WOULD BE
SEPTEMBER AND THEY LATER WOULD
NOT STOP BY.
NOT THE FACT MEMBERS MEMBERS
BACK.
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE THAT WE
HAD A DRESSED AT THAT SPECIFIC
QUESTION PRIOR.
TO OKAY I'LL BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
YES -- I
WANT TO THANK --
MISS CERVANTES FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FOR IT WOMEN WHO COME THE
FACULTY TO TO SHARE YOUR IDEAS I
THINK IT IS.
IT IS --
THIS HEARTENING TO ME AS A AS A
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE HAVE FOLKS
WHO GO ON TO OUR INSTITUTIONS
AND WHAT MEET IN HAND UP WITH
SUCH TREMENDOUS DEBT.
OF IN THAT WAS NOT THE VISION
FOR CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM FOR PEOPLE TO END UP WITH
ENORMOUS DEBT.
AND SO -- IN
TERMS OF THE CONSTANT INCREASE
IN PRICE IN THE COST AND ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS IS REALLY
QUITE TRAGIC AND AND OBVIOUSLY
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT THAT IS MORE SIGNIFICANT
THAN WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS ARE NOT.
IN DEBT IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT
SEEMS AS IF IT'S A DEEP HOLE.
OF FOR THOSE WHO ARE POOR AND
STRUGGLING AND YET I KNOW HOW
VALUABLE YOUR ROLE IS AT THE AT
THE UNIVERSITIES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
I WORK WITH A LOT OF PART TIME
FACULTY AT YOUR DEPARTMENT FOR
PROBABLY THIRTY OF THE FORTY
YEARS I WAS A CYNICAL STATE.
AND I KNOW THAT I WORK WITH SOME
AMAZING PART TIME FACULTY WHO
GAVE LOTS OF TIME.
AND AND MUCH NEEDED TIME TO OUR
STUDENTS AND GRADING PAPERS AND
AND COUNSELING THEM ON THE SIDE
AND HELPING THEM STAY IN SCHOOL
AND AT THE SAME TIME RUNNING ALL
OVER THE CITY TO TEACH CLASSES
TO TRY TO MAINTAIN A LIFE
THEMSELVES.
AND I DON'T KNOW OF ANY PART
TIME FACULTY THAT TIME FACULTY
AS THEIR ONLY LIFE OF THE THEIR
WEALTH ONLY MONEY THEY WERE
MAKING.
WHO ACTUALLY PROSPERED FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE OTHER THAN IN THE
EMOTIONAL SENSE OF BEING ABLE TO
GET BACK SOMETHING THAT THEY SO
STRONGLY BELIEVE THEM?
BUT THEY OFTEN SUFFERED
FINANCIALLY THEY SUFFERED IN
TERMS OF LOANS THAT THEY HAVE TO
PAY THEY SUFFERED AND NOT BEING
ABLE TO LIVE THE LIFESTYLE THAT
THEY WANTED BECAUSE OF THEIR
INCOME WAS SO LOW.
BECAUSE OF ALL THE THINGS THAT
ARE THAT ENCOMPASSED IN IT AND
IT REALLY IS A SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE TO AS AS A STATE LOOK AT
VERY CAREFULLY.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WOULD NOT
ONCE A CONTRIBUTING TO THE
POVERTY.
OF CALIFORNIA AND CONTRIBUTING
TO THE NEGATIVE THINGS THAT WE
CLAIM WE FIGHT EVERY DAY AND
FOLKS WHO HAVE GONE TO SCHOOL
AND THAT MEANS DEGREES AND WORK
HARD.
AND STILL A STRUGGLING THAT'S
NOT THE VISION YOU HAD I'M SURE
FOR YOUR LIFE AND FOR YOURSELF --
SO I'M I'M REALLY PLEASED ABOUT
THIS COMING FORWARD I I KNOW
THERE IS JUSTIFICATION FOR IT
BECAUSE NO FACULTY TEACHES MORE
THAN --
WHO'S A FULL TIME TENURE TRACK
FACULTY MORE THAN TWELVE HOURS A
WEEK MOST OF US TEACH NINE I
TAUGHT THREE SOMETIMES AND SIX
DEPENDING ON THE OTHER THING IS
THAT I WAS CONSIDERED FULL TIME.
AND ARE AND SOLD MOST OF THE
TIME IF WE REALLY.
WOULD WE FORMULATED CORRECTLY --
IT IS THREE TO FOUR HOURS OR
MORE PER HOUR THAT YOU TEACH IN
DEALING WITH MEETING WITH
STUDENTS GRADING PAPERS
PREPARING FOR CLASSES AND DOING
YOUR RESEARCH BECAUSE YOU ARE
ALSO REACH EXPECTED INDIVIDUALS.
AND SELL PEOPLE SOMETIMES LOOK
AT PEOPLE HEY BECAUSE I'M ON A
LECTURE I MEAN SOMETHING AND SO
IT REALLY IS --
A UNFORTUNATE AND SAD FOR ME TO
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO INDIVIDUAL
SO DEDICATED AND SO COMMITTED
AND YOU ONLY REPRESENT A SMALL
AMOUNT OF THE HUGE NUMBER OF
PART TIME FACULTY.
WHO ARE SO DEDICATED TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
PARTICULARLY AND OFTENTIMES TO
OUR OUR OUR C. ISSUE WHEN YOU
SEE AS WELL?
SO DEDICATED TO OUR STUDENTS
GIVING SO MUCH AND RECEIVING SO
LITTLE IN RETURN OTHER THAN THE
SATISFACTION OF HELPING SOMEBODY
ELSE SO I I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS.
I STRONG SUPPORT I THINK THIS
SHOULD NOT BE THE BEGINNING THE
ENDBUT THE BEGINNING OF OUR
EFFORTS TO REALLY BE CAREFULLY
EXAMINED WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
THIS SYSTEM.
TO FACULTY OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
PARTICULARLY TO PART TIME
FACULTY AND THE COMMUTER COLLEGE
FACULTY IN PARTICULAR THAT HAS A
NECESSARILY NEGOTIATED THE SAME
TIME AGREEMENT THAT WE HAVE IT'S
AN EAGLE STATE.
AT THE C. ISSUE AND THAT WE HAVE
AT THE UC CAMPUS --
SO I I REALLY APPLAUD YOU FOR
WANTING TO BE THERE FOR STUDENTS
I THANK YOU FOR THAT I THANK YOU
FOR BEING COMMITTED TO THE
PROFESSION.
THERE IS PROBABLY NO GREATER
PROFESSION IN THE WORLD IN
TEACHING THAT'S THE TRUTH AND
TOUCHING THE HARD TO AND AND
SPIRITS AND THE FUTURE OF YOUNG
PEOPLE.
BUT YOU SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
SUFFER IN THE PROCESS AND I
THINK THAT IS AND THE UNFAIRNESS
THAT WE HAVE THE WHICH ARE YOU
YOU'RE HELPING OUR CHILDREN. TO
GET EDUCATED AND GROW AND
DEVELOP AND YET WE HAVE NOT DONE
WHAT IS RIGHT TO BUY YOU.
SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT IT FORWARD
AND I HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
OF HIGHER IT THAT THIS IS ONLY
THE BEGINNING.
OF OUR ARE MOVING INTO AN AREA
ASSN CREW HOPEFULLY MAKE THEM
FEEL NOT ONLY GOOD ABOUT GIVING
BUT GOOD ABOUT RECEIVING AS WELL
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
THE RIVER COULD HAVE A MOTION.
I'M OF THE BILL [inaudible]
CHOI.
I ALSO WAS A PART TIME FACULTY
AND I'VE OFTEN SAID AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WOULD NOT EXIST.
WERE IT NOT FOR THE PART TIME
FACULTY IN OTHER WORDS THE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES EXIST BECAUSE
OF THE PART TIME FACULTY.
AND ON THE BACKS OF THE PART
TIME FACULTY.
SO I'M I'M VERY HAPPY --
ALSO TO BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
AND STRONGLY AGREE WITH DOCTOR
WEBER THAT HOPEFULLY MAYBE THIS
IS A BEGINNING.
AND NOT THE END.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY DOCTOR
WEBER.
SECOND BY DOCTOR CHOI.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE MATTEUCCI WE'RE
TEACHING I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY.
DALY I LEVINE I LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I GEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT LEADERS OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WE'LL GO WITH THIS [inaudible]
HE YOU MAY WANT TO WAIT
.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS STARTING WITH MISTER
PATTERSON AND THEN DOCTOR WEBER
HAD PLEASE FIX DOCTOR WEBER. FOR
STUDENTS THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF
WHICH I AM LIKE [inaudible]
ITEM [inaudible]
EIGHT THANKS.
TO AT EIGHT FIVE THREE TWO YEAH
I THINK THEY HAVE SOME WITNESSES
IF THEY WANT TO COME FORWARD
ALSO THEY'RE HERE --
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB FIVE
THREE TWO THE C. ISSUE PARKING
FAIRNESS ACT.
AND I HAVE TO CONFESS I DIDN'T
OLD STUDENTS PAID SO MUCH FOR
PARKING AND IN COMPARISON TO
FACULTY.
I FEEL GUILTY NOW AS I REALIZE
WHAT WE DIDN'T PAY.
OF THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
TRAINING OBTAINING A COLLEGE
DEGREE HAS RISEN SIGNIFICANTLY
IN RECENT YEARS.
ASIDE FROM TUITION COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND KERR COST OF
HOUSING FOOD TRANSPORTATION FOOD
BOOKS AND PERSONAL EXPENSES.
AS RESULT OF COSTLY NOT TUITION
EXPENSES HOUSING IN SECURITY.
THE HIGH COST OF STUDENT PARKING
FURTHER EXACERBATES COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES.
DATA FROM UP AND DOWN CALIFORNIA
X. ACROSS THE TWENTY THREE C.
ISSUE DID DEMONSTRATE STUDENTS
DISPROPORTIONATE PAY EGREGIOUS
PRICES TO PARK ON CAMPUS.
WITH STUDENTS PAYING UP TO FOUR
TO FIVE TIMES MORE THAN FACULTY
AND STAFF.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE STUDENTS OF
THIS ISSUE PAYING THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT DOLLARS A
SEMESTER FOR PARKING.
WHICH IS SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
DOLLARS A YEAR JUST TO GET TO
CLASS THIS IS CONSIDERABLE AND
BURDENSOME COSTS TO STUDENTS.
I THINK FACULTY PAYS ABOUT SIXTY
STE SOME DOLLARS WITH OF
SEMESTER SO.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
AB FIVE THIRTY TWO AIMS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE ON THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENTION BY PREVENTING
BY PREVENTING STUDENTS FROM
BEING UNFAIRLY BURDENED WITH
ACOSTA PARKING ON CAMPUS COMP
COMPARE FULLY FROM ALL OF THE
CAMPUS AFFILIATES WITH THE
FACULTY STAFF OR ADMINISTRATORS.
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE CAMPUS JUST
STUDENT PARKING FEES SO THAT NO
LONGER THAT THEY NO LONGER
SUBSIDIZE THE PARKING RATES OF
C. ISSUE FACULTY STAFF
ADMINISTRATORS.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WITH ME TODAY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AB FIVE THREE
TWO IS ATTICUS RADIUS THE
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT AND C.
ISSUE CHANNEL ISLANDS.
AND HANNAH BLACKED OUT A
LEGISLATIVE POLICY ANALYST WITH
C. CSA.
A GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS HANNAH
BACKSIDE AND I'M THE LEGISLATIVE
POLICY ANALYST FOR THE COST
EIGHT STUDENT ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS THE NEARLY HALF A
MILLION CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
WHERE THEN PULL THANKFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER FOR THE
WORK SHE'S DONE ON AB FIVE THREE
TWO AND ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL?
THE BILL SIMPLY PUT REQUIRES
THAT THE CSU CHARGE STUDENTS THE
LEAST FOR THEIR PARKING AND
GIVES THE INSTITUTION OVER TWO
YEARS TO RESET THESE PARKING
RATES.
THERE'S A GREAT NEED FOR AB FIVE
THREE TWO TO ANY CSU STUDENT
ASKED THEM ABOUT AN ISSUE THAT
THEY ARE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT ALMOST ANY STUDENT WOULD
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THEIR
CHALLENGE WITH PARKING COSTS.
AS YOU ALREADY KNOW THE
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES OUR
STUDENTS FACE ARE DEEP AND BROAD
ALTHOUGH SYSTEM WIDE TUITION AND
FEES ARE RELATIVELY LOW COMPARED
IT TO SIMILAR INSTITUTIONS.
CSU STUDENTS REPORT CHALLENGES
AND A FOURTEEN THEIR TOTAL COST
OF EDUCATION INCLUDING HIGH
RATES OF FOOD AND SECURITY FORTY
ONE POINT 6% AND HOMELESSNESS
TEN POINT 9%.
MANY CSU STUDENTS TO DRIVE TO
CAMPUS DO SO BECAUSE THEY MUST
THEY EITHER WORK ONE OR MORE
JOBS IN ADDITION TO BEING A
STUDENT OR CANNOT AFFORD HOUSING
CLOSE THE UNIVERSITY.
OR ATTEND A CAMPUS NOT WELL
SERVED BY PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
PARKING ON CAMPUS IS THEIR ONLY
OPTION TO GET TO AND FROM SCHOOL.
WHAT WE ARE AWARE THAT THERE IS
AN ACTIVE J. LACK AUDIT ON CSU
PARKING WE BELIEVE THAT THE
AUDIT FINDINGS WILL COMPLEMENT
AB?
FIVE THREE TWO AND RESEARCHING
PARKING COSTS SPECIFICALLY WE AT
CSSA DISCOVERED THAT STUDENTS
PAY MORE FOR PARKING AND STAFF
FACULTY AND ADMINISTRATION ON
EVERY CAMPUS.
THESE PARKING RATES ARE DUE TO
TWO MAIN FACTORS THE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS THAT STAFF AND
FACULTY SAT WITH THE CSU AND THE
SELF SUPPORT REQUIREMENT OF THE
PARKING FACILITIES ON CAMPUS
WHICH MEANS NO OTHER FUNDS CAN
BE USED TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR
BUDGETS.
WE UNDERSTAND HOW CRUCIAL IT IS
THAT OUR INSTITUTION HAS THE
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS
FINANCE THE CONSTRUCTION OF NEW
FACILITIES HOWEVER BY SETTING
AND YOU LEGISLATIVE REQUIREMENT
ON PARKING RATES WE BELIEVE A
POSITIVE PRESSURE WILL BE PLACED
ON OUR ADMINISTRATION.
WHERE THEY CAN NO LONGER AGREE
TO SUCH AN UNFAIR AGREEMENT
WHERE STUDENTS MUST PAY HIGHER
PARKING RATES TO SUBSIDIZE A
FUNCTIONAL BENEFIT FOR FACULTY
AND STAFF?
WELL STUDENTS BELIEVE THAT WELL
COMPENSATED EMPLOYEES ARE
CRITICAL TO OUR CAMPUS CULTURE
AND SAID A STUDENT SUCCESS THE
ISSUE HERE IS FAIRNESS.
STUDENTS ARE THE ONLY GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT PAID TO BE ON
CAMPUS.
RATHER THEY PAY TUITION AND FEES
TO BE THERE AND ARE THE LEAST
ABLE TO SHOULDER THESE UNFAIR
PARKING COSTS.
IT IS A CHALLENGING POLICY ISSUE
TO CONSIDER --
THIS IS NO WHERE SOLVABLE TOWN
INSTITUTIONAL LEADERSHIP MAKE
DIFFICULT CHOICES AND EXECUTE
COMPLICATED AND CHALLENGING
THINGS EVERY DAY BUT WE HOPE
THAT GIVEN THE CHOICE BETWEEN
CHALLENGING AND FAIR.
EVERYONE CHOOSES FAIRNESS WE
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
HER WORK ON THAT CENTER JR I
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR MEDINA FELLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME'S ATTICUS REYES AND THE
CIGAR PRESIDENT BECAUSE THE
CHANNEL ISLANDS GO DOLPHINS.
I'M ALSO THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
CALIFORNIA STATES IN ASSOCIATION --
I WANNA THANK PERSONALLY GERMAN
DEVELOPMENT COME SPEAK TODAY AS
WELL AS DOCTOR WEBER FOR HER
AMAZING LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE --
IT'S SOMETHING THAT GETS
OVERLOOKED VERY OFTEN AS WE TALK
ABOUT HIGHER EDUCATION WE TALK A
LOT ABOUT TUITION WE TALK ABOUT
COST OF BOOKS TO TALK ABOUT COST
OF HOUSING COST OF FOOD.
SOME OF THE NUMBERS THAT HANNAH
BROUGHT UP A REALLY STAGGERING
ARE FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND STUDENT POPULATION IN
THE CSU SYSTEM WHICH IS A
MASSIVE STRUCTURE. 41% OF THE
STUDENTS ARE HUNGRY. TEN POINT
9% SINCE ARE HOMELESS.
SO WE TALK ABOUT THESE THINGS IS
A REALLY POOR BUT ONE OF THE
MAIN ISSUES LIKE IT'S WATER THE
RUGS PARKING.
WE FOUND IS THROUGHOUT CAMPUSES
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCREPANCIES.
AND STUDENTS DON'T GET PAID TO
GO TO SCHOOL.
THEY ACTUALLY.
PAY TO GO TO SCHOOLS WAS ANOTHER
FEE THAT GETS OUT ON TOP OF IT.
CHANNEL LINE SPECIFICALLY
STUDENTS PAY ONE HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE DOLLARS A SEMESTER. TO
ATTEND SCHOOL.
THERE FACULTY COUNTERPART PAY.
NINETY EIGHT THE STUDENTS ARE
PAYING TWICE AS MUCH.
AS DOCTOR WEBER BROUGHT UP MY
COLLEAGUES AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SAN MARCOS PAY THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT DOLLARS A
SEMESTER. FOR THEIR FACULTY PAY
SIXTY NINE DOLLARS.
SEE THE THESE ARE DISCREPANCIES
THAT REALLY AFFECTS STUDENTS
ACCESSIBILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
AND HIGHER EDUCATION.
THIS ISSUES REALLY PERSONAL TO
ME BECAUSE I'M ONE OF THE
STUDENTS I COMMUTE FIVE DAYS A
WEEK AN HOUR EACH WAY.
SANTEE FIVE MILES IN TOTAL.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
AS WE TALKED ABOUT COST OF
LIVING AND COST TO ATTEND HIGHER
EDUCATION I CHOSE TO STAY HOME.
BECAUSE I COULD PAY FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION ONLY COST ME SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS A SEMESTER.
VERSUS LIVING ON CAMPUS THAT
WOULD NOW COST ME TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS SEMESTER.
WE HAVE A LOT OF STUDENTS I'M
NOT AN OUTLINE. 70% OF OUR
STUDENT POPULATION ACOSTA
CHALLENGE COMMUTES.
VAST MAJORITY THOSE 70% OF THAT
ALREADY EXISTING SOBRE SOME
PUBLISHED HAS TO BY THE PARKING
PERMIT.
CHANNEL ISLANDS IS FIFTEEN
MINUTES AWAY FROM THE FREEWAY.
ITS INFORMANTS BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS
BUT IT'S NOT AN URBAN AREA.
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IS NOT
VERY ACCESSIBLE TO THE CAMPUS.
AND IF YOU'RE DRIVING ALREADY AN
HOUR HOUR AND A HALF.
YOU JUST WANT TO GET TO CLASS.
AS CALIFORNIA'S STRIVES TO
ENSURE AND ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE STATE HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO MEMBER THE EFFECTS
AND RESULTS OF THESE FEES.
CHANNEL ISLANDS AND THE CSU IN
GENERAL IS A REALLY TRANSFORM
THE STRUCTURE TO TRANSFORM
INSTITUTION.
CHANNEL ISLANDS SERVES A
POPULATION AT 52% HISPANIC. 60%
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE.
AND 80% PO GRANT RECIPIENTS.
HOWEVER MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES AT
CHANNEL ISLANDS.
WHO ALREADY STRUGGLING TO PAY
TUITION? TO PAY FOR BOOKS TO PAY
FOR HOUSING TO PAY FOR FOOD.
THE STRESS OUT ABOUT THIS ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE DOLLAR FEE.
THEY HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT CLASSES
CAN THEY TAKE ON WHAT DAYS THAT
THEY CAN BY THE DAILY PARKING
PERMIT.
RIGHT IN THE SEMESTER IF THEY
CAN ONLY GO TO SCHOOL TWO DAYS A
WEEK.
THEY WANTED TO PAY THAT ONE
NINETY FIVE THEY COULD JUST PAY
THE SIX DOLLARS A DAY.
BUT WITH ALREADY LIMITED CLASS
AVAILABILITY AND CLASS SCHEDULES.
THAT'S PROLONGING PEOPLE'S
ACADEMIC CAREER.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THIS FEES
REALLY SYMPTOMATIC OF A LARGER
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE.
I'LL JUST FINISH UP.
SOON TO REMEMBER THAT THIS FEE
THE ONE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
DOLLAR FEES IN THE PARKING FEES
ON OUR CAMPUSES.
IT'S NOT COVERED BY FINANCIAL
AID IT'S NOT WAIVED.
BY THE UNIVERSITY FOR LOWER
ECONOMIC STUDENTS A MARGIN AS
INDIVIDUALS IT'S EXPECTED TO BE
PAID IF YOU WANT TO ATTEND THE
UNIVERSITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU'D COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE GIVE YOUR NAME
[inaudible]
WE REPRESENT.
CHARACTER HOME ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS OF SAN FRANCISCO STATE
SUPPORT.
NO ALL MORE US STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE
AND SEE US AS A BOARD MEMBER IN
SUPPORT.
I'M RHONDA MARCELLO'S LOBBY
QUIRK MA'AM --
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND I'M IN
SUPPORT.
FROM AVAIL NOW MARTINEZ FRESNO
STATE ISSUED ASSOCIATED SINCE
INCORPORATED IN SUPPORT.
SHANNON SWANSON RESIDENT ADVISER
AND STERN ASSISTANT TO PRESIDENT
NELSON AT SACRAMENTO STATE
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR LEVINE.
AS A GREAT BILL DR WEBBER THANK
YOU FOR INTRODUCING IT THANK YOU
TO CSSA --
FOR FOR MAKE ME PROUD AS A
FORMER CSSA CHAIR FOR RAISING
THIS ISSUE HOW DID I MISS THIS.
TWENTY SOMETHING YEARS AGO --
MAYBE THEY ARE CONFUSED WEREN'T
QUITE AS HIGH IT WOULD HAVE CAR
SIX ACTUALLY.
I LIKE THAT A LIKE THAT --
BUT YOU LIKE IT IT REALLY.
OPENS UP THE FLAWS OF HOW WE WE
IS THE LEGISLATURE FORCED THE
CSU. TO FINANCE PARKING AND IRA
ARTHUR AGE PRE EARTHQUAKE WE HAD
A PARKING PROBLEM.
AFTER THE EARTHQUAKE WHEN THE
GARAGES COLLAPSED YOU KNOW WE
HAD A HUGE PARKING PROBLEM AND
NOW IS WE'VE.
STRUGGLED SO HARD AS HE CLIMBED%
OUT OF THE RECESSION TO OPEN UP
THE SEATS FOR STUDENTS FOR A
QUALIFIED TO GO TO A CSU THERE'S
AN EVEN BIGGER PROBLEM BECAUSE
WE GOT MORE STUDENTS ARE GOING
THANKFULLY BECAUSE THE BUDGET IS
GOOD AND PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GO
TO COLLEGE.
AND IT EXACERBATES THE PARKING
DEMAND THAT WE HAVE AND THEN THE
NEED FOR MORE PARKING THAT NEEDS
TO BE MAINTAINED.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE MORE
STUDENTS THAN ANYONE ELSE AND SO
WE FINANCE IT ON THE BACK OF
STUDENTS THE OTHER PROBLEM THAT
IS REALLY FLAWED AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO WORK WITH.
THE FACULTY ON THIS IS HOW THEY
BARGAINED FOR A LOWER PRICE AND
THEY DO A GOOD JOB.
AT BARGAINING FOR A LOWER PRICE
BUT AT THE EXPENSE OF EVERYONE
ELSE.
AND SO THERE IS A VALUE FOR A
PARKING SPOT THERE IS THE COST
OF MAINTAINING A PARKING SPOT
AND THAT IS REALLY WHAT WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT WHEN WE ARE
WORKING WITH --
OUR EMPLOYEES ON TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE PRICE A
SPOT FOR AN EMPLOYEE.
NOW OF COURSE WE SHOULD ALL BE
EXTRAORDINARILY UPSET THAT
STUDENTS ARE PAYING MORE THAN
ADMINISTRATORS.
AND THAT'S THAT'S A HUGE FLOCK --
RIGHT THERE --
SO YOU KNOW I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THE
BILL -- I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS BILL FIXES
THAT PROBLEM BECAUSE WE HAVE.
TO UNDO THE WAY THAT WE
BARGAINED FOR SPACES AND WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO FINANCE
THE PARKING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE SO BADLY NEED ESPECIALLY IF
YOU WANT.
TO OPEN UP THE CAMPUSES TO EVEN
MORE STUDENTS SO --
I APPLAUD YOU FOR WORKING ON
THIS FOR EXPOSING THIS ISSUE AND
ALSO FOR THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MR BLUE --
I GENERALLY AGREE WITH --
MR LEVIN'S REMARKS --
ACT I WANT TO POINT OUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE --
IS IMPORTANT BUT I I I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
BALANCED APPROACH AND TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION OUR CLIMATE --
GOALS OF WHEN WE SUBSIDIZE
PARKING WE ENCOURAGE DRIVING AND
I UNDERSTAND I TAKE YOUR POINT
THAT FOR US SOME STUDENTS --
THE COMMUTE --
THE A TRANSIT COMMUTERS
IMPOSSIBLE OR BICYCLE COMMUTE IS
ISN'T POSSIBLE --
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE FOR A FORGET
IF WE'RE GONNA.
WE WE REALLY SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT NOT RACING TO THE BOTTOM FOR
PARKING FEES --
I I THINK THE INEQUITY HERE IS
THAT AND I YOU KNOW THE HOPE THE
FACULTY DOESN'T COME AFTER ME ON
THIS BUT WE'RE WE'RE KIND OF
WE'RE WE'RE GIVING A BREAK TO
FACULTY WHERE YOU KNOW WE SHOULD
BE GIVING IT SOMEWHERE ELSE WE
SHOULDN'T BE DOING IT.
HERE ON PARKING IT'S KIND OF
ANTIQUATED THINKING THAT WE
SHOULD --
PROVIDE -- A
BREAK TO ANY GROUP ON PARKING
WORK COSTS.
OF FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SO THE
PARKING SPACE --
OTHER OUR MAINTENANCE COSTS --
BUT I THINK MORE IMPORTANT TO
TELL ME IS --
THAT WERE ENCOURAGING MORE
PEOPLE TO DRIVE WHICH IS
COMPLETELY CONTRARY TO A LOT OF
THE WORK THAT WE DO HERE IN THE
CAPITAL.
ON ON CLIMATE --
GOING FORWARD I'M GONNA VOTE FOR
THE BILL IF I DIDN'T SAY THAT
ALREADY BUT A GOING FORWARD
DOCTOR WEBER AS YOU THINK THIS
THROUGH AND AND TAKE A MAN'S
PERHAPS INCLUDE SOME%
REQUIREMENTS WERE --
RIDE SHARE PROGRAMS AND AND
PERHAPS YOU SOME OF THE FUNDING
FROM PARKING --
TO PROVIDE TRANSIT --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING --
AT LEAST AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL IS PROVIDING FREE
OR SUBSIDIZED TRANSIT PASSES --
FOR AS MANY STUDENTS AND AND
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL SO --
JUST PUTTING SOME IDEAS OUT
THERE -- SO
THE PERHAPS THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL CAN BE EXPANDED AND AND
INCLUDE THESE ITEMS.
MR GAVE UP.
YES HANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
WITNESSES FOR BRINGING THIS FORD
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
I DO WANNA SOCIAIS MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA MONICA.
AND YOU PERHAPS IT'S MAYBE I'M
JUST UNDERSTANDING A LITTLE BIT
OF THAT MISUNDERSTANDING A
LITTLE BIT OF THE REGULATORY
REGULATORY ARCHITECTURE HERE
RELATIVE. TO TO MISTER LEVINE --
AND I'M LOOKING AT THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IN ONE PLACE FOR TALKS
ABOUT FIND ANOTHER PLACE OR TALK
ABOUT FEES.
BUT I ALSO WORRY ABOUT
INADVERTENT CROSS SUBSIDIZATION
THE KIND OF BEHAVIOR THAT WERE
ENCOURAGING WILL THIS ULTIMATELY
ON SOME CAMPUSES UNDERSTAND IT
MAY BE DIFFERENT ON YOUR CAMPUS.
ACTUALLY MEAN THAT STUDENTS WHO
AREN'T DRIVING ARE SUBSIDIZED
STUDENTS WHO ARE CHOOSING TO
DRIVE AND THAT WOULD BE A
CONCERN OF MINE --
BUT I COULDN'T I COULDN'T TELL
FROM THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
WHETHER THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE
WE MAY ACTUALLY BE YOU KNOW THAT
THIS MONEY IF WE'RE GOING TO IF
IT'S NOT CAN BE PAID BY CERTAIN
STUDENTS AMANDA BE BE BE PAYING
BY OTHERS.
AND OR IS IT GOING TO IS THE
BURNING A FALLEN STUDENTS WERE
TAKING -- I
THINK THAT'S NOT THE CASE I
COULDN'T TELL FOR SURE FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS BUT I WAS
JUST --
WOULD BE INTERESTED THE AUTHORS --
COMMENTS ON THAT.
WHAT YOU KNOW THE HOPE IN THIS?
THE ISSUE THAT'S COMING FORWARD
IS NOT ALWAYS JUST THAT THE
ACTUAL NUMBER THE COST BUT THE
UNFAIRNESS OF IT.
AND THE IF THERE IS A COST THAT
SHOULD BE BORN IN THE AREA OF
TRANCE IN PARKING IT SHOULD BE
SHARED GENERALLY ACROSS THE
BOARD -- AND
NOT NECESSARILY ONE BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW IT IS IS THAT THE
STUDENTS OF SUBSIDIZING THE
FACULTY WHICH IS BACKWARDS IN
SOME WAY BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE
STUDENTS HAVE A GROUP THAT
FACULTY SHOULD HAVE A GREATER
INCOME THAN THE STUDENTS AND THE
AND THE WAY IT IS NOW IT'S NOT
THAT.
I MAY END UP BEING ALL THE SAME
COST BUT JUST DISTRIBUTED
DIFFERENTLY --
SO BECAUSE THEIR CONCERN IS THAT
THIS IS UNFAIR NOT THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE THREE PARKING OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT WHY
SHOULD A FACULTY.
A WHY SHOULD I PAY FOURTEEN
DOLLARS A WEEK A WHAT MONTH
WHATEVER IT IS A SIXTY DOLLARS
FOR THE SEMESTER AND EVERYBODY
AND THEIR PAIN THREE HUNDRED AND
SOMETHING YOU KNOW SO THAT IN
ITSELF IS AN INEQUITY AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE AN INEQUITY OF THE SYSTEM
THAT THEY SHOULD NOT BE PAYING
MORE THAN FACULTY NOW HOW THEY
CHOOSE TO DIVVY IT UP BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THE FACULTY.
THEY'RE PAYING FOR BASICALLY THE
FACULTY TO PARK YOU KNOW THEY'RE
PAYING THE BURDEN OF THE FACULTY
WHICH IS NOT WHAT.
SHOULD HAPPEN BUT FACULTIES ABLE
TO LOBBY AND I THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT'S THERE BUT
IT'S NOT SO MUCH ABOUT THAT IS
REALLY A MUCH MUCH MORE ABOUT
THAT PASSING IT ON TO THE OTHER
STUDENTS WHO DON'T.
DRIVE BUT IF IF THE DRIVERS IN
THE PARKERS ARE GOING TO PAY.
FOR A PARKING IT SHOULD BE
EVENLY DISTRIBUTED AND NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY DISTRIBUTED
TO STUDENTS WHO DON'T HAVE
LOBBYISTS TO LOBBY FOR THEM AND
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S THEIR
ISSUE AND AND AND AND AND
WHETHER NOT --
THE OTHER ISSUE OF OF WHAT IT'S
NOT TO BE PASSED ON TO OTHER
STUDENTS HOPEFULLY THE CAMPUS
WON'T DO THAT --
ADDITIONALLY IN TERMS OF THE
ENVIRONMENT THERE IT WOULD BE
GREAT IF THERE WAS PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
BUT YOU STILL HAVE THE ISSUE OF
NOT WANTING TO PAY MORE THAN
YOUR FAIR SHARE FOR PARKING IF
YOU CHOSE TO DRIVE.
BUT MANY CAMPUSES DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
THAT'S A THAT'S CONSISTENT
THAT'S THAT'S THAT CAN GET THEM
TO AND FROM CAMPUS AS WELL AS IF
THEY HAVE A PART TIME JOB ARE
THEY GOING TO GET HOME GET TO
THE PART TIME JOB.
THE THE REALITY IS OUR PUBLIC
TRANSIT SYSTEM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IS NOT NECESSARILY PEOPLE
FRIENDLY.
AND UNFRIENDLY TOWARD PEOPLE WEB
LIVES THAT BASICALLY DEMAND THAT
THEY BE PLACES QUICKLY AND SO
THAT IS AN ONGOING CHALLENGE --
I THINK AS CITIES IN AS WE WE DO
A LOT OF THINGS THAT OBVIOUSLY
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GET ON THE
FREEWAYS --
AND WE DO A LOT IN TERMS OF OUR
OWN PLANNING AND NOT PLANNING
APPROPRIATELY --
WE'VE DONE VERY LITTLE IN TERMS
OF RAPID TRANSIT IN IN THE STATE
IN TERMS OF MAKING IT CONVENIENT
WHEN WE DO IT IN A THOUGHTFUL
WAY IT DOES ENHANCE I KNOW THAT
IT'S ENABLE STATE.
OF PARKING WAS ONE OF THE WORST
THINGS IN THE WORLD ENTRANCE
WITH AND GETTING ON AND OFF THE
FREEWAY WAS A NIGHTMARE IT'S AN
EAGLE STATE ON THE ON THAT MESA.
BUT THE FACT THAT THEY NOW HAVE
THE TRANSIT COMING THROUGH THE
CAMPUS.
AND AND AND AND DROPPING
STUDENTS OFF MANY THOSE STUDENTS
NOW TAKE THE TRANSPORTATION THEY
LIVE IN OKLAHOMA THEY LIVE AT
THE BEACH WHERE IT IS.
AND THAT THAT --
TRANSIT SYSTEM IS RIGHT THERE ON
CAMPUS.
AND MANY OF OUR STUDENTS USE IT
BUT THAT'S RARE THAT'S NOT ON
EVERY CAMPUS.
AND SO AS A RESULT YOU HAVE
FOLKS WHO HAVE TO DRIVE BECAUSE
IF NOT IT TAKES AND BEFORE THE
BEFORE THAT WAS ON CAMPUS IT
WILL TAKE STUDENTS FOR EVER TO
pTHE BUS DIDN'T COME.
ALWAYS DIRECTLY THERE TO PUT A
WHERE YOU WHERE YOU HAVE TO GO
DOWNTOWN COME BACK AND THEN IF
YOU HAD TO GO TO A JOB.
YOU TO FIGURE THAT OUT IN THE
MIDST OF ALL YOUR CLASSES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE SO ALL WE HAVE
TO HAVE STOP OBVIOUSLY PUBLIC
TRANSIT THAT THAT IS THAT
SENSIBLE AND WORKS WITH STUDENTS
SCHEDULE.
BUT EVEN IN THE MIDST OF ALL OF
THAT THESE.
TWO THE FACT THAT THEY SHOULD
NOT BE PAYING MORE THAN FACULTY
FOR TRANSPORTATION TOOK FOR
PARKING REGARDLESS OF WHAT IT
WHETHER THEY CHOOSE TO DRIVER
NOT DRIVE OR WHATEVER THAT.
IT IS IT'S JUST UNFAIR THAT
THERE HAS BEEN PUT ON STUDENTS
TO REALLY CARRY THE BURDEN OF
PUBLIC A PARKING ON CAMPUS IS
JUST BASED ON THE AMOUNT THAT
THEY HAVE TO PAY IN COMPARISON
TO FACULTY.
MR CHOI.
I THANK YOU I HAVE WATER SO
COUPLE QUESTIONS --
TO A DOCTOR WEBER --
I THINK THIS IS --
PARKING FAIRNESS ACT IS TO IN
PRINCE BORDER BEREA.
SUPPORTABLE IN THE TO QUESTION
NUMBER ONE IS THAT --
YOUR BILL IS A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY VANESSA.
A PARKING FAIRNESS ACT OUT.
OF WITH DISH.
THE NOMINAL MAY BE NOT JUST
THOSE OF CAL STATE THAT BUT THE
UC SYSTEMS --
AND THEN ALSO OR LAW --
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO WHAT
CAN WE MAKE IT OR THE PUBLIC
ALWAYS AS HOW DO YOU EITHER
ELEPHANT TO DO IT ONE BY.
ITSELF.
THIS IS THE FIRST BITE OF THE
ELEPHANT I'M NOT SURE OF ALL THE
ELEPHANTS HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM
ALTHOUGH THAT'S THE ISSUE THEY
DEAL WITH THE C. ISSUE AND THE
AND AND AND AND JUSTICE IS THERE.
CLEARLY WE NEED TO LOOK AT THAT
YOU SEE WE KNOW THAT YOU SEE
THAT ANYTHING WE DO WITH THAT
WAS MERELY A SUGGESTION.
SO -- YEAH
YOU KNOW --
AND IF SO WHAT UNDER THE
INTERNET --
THAN THEY THE COLLEGES ARE HUGE
THE SYSTEM ITSELF IS LARGE
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER OF
COMMUNICABLE JUST.
AND I'VE BEEN SOME COMMUNICABLE
JUST WHAT PARKING WAS FREE.
BECAUSE IT WAS SO RULES SO FAR
OUT THE ITSELF UP THEIR ISSUE IS
THAT THEY REPRESENTING THE CAL
STATE SYSTEM SO WE WANT TO FOCUS
ON THAT BUT THAT DOES NOT MEET
AT ANY TIME BUT YOU CAN'T DO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ONE OR THE UC CAN ONE YOU KNOW
THAT'S OKAY SO I GET IT NUMBER
TWO IS THAT I HEARD THAT THIS IS
A PART OF THE UNION SO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE NOT
BECOME THE FACTOR FOR UNION --
THE SHE ASIAN SO SO EVERYBODY
WOULD PAY THE EQUAL AMOUNT.
WELL IT IT OBVIOUSLY WILL BE A
FACTOR AND MAYBE THE FACT THAT
NOW THE STUDENTS HAVE TO PAY IT
MAY BE LESS OF A BARGAINING.
FOR THE THE FACULTY THE FACULTY
DIDN'T COME OUT AND OPPOSES
BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTOOD THE
UNFAIRNESS OF IT YOU KNOW COULD
HAVE COME IN AND THEY CHOSE NOT
TO BECAUSE THEY FELT IT WAS
UNFAIR.
THAT THAT THAT WHEN THEY LOOK AT
IT THE ODD I DON'T THINK IS
THEIR INTENT AS THEIR
NEGOTIATING THEMSELVES TO
BASICALLY DO THIS TO STUDENTS
WITH THIS IS JUST.
THE THE THE END RESULT OF WHAT
HAPPENS SO THEY DID NOT COME
OPPOSED TO THIS BECAUSE THEY
EMPATHIZE AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S SOMEONE FAIRNESS IN THE
SYSTEM SO --
THAT'S WHY THEY DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR TWO YEARS SO
THE CAMPUS GETS A CHANCE TO WORK
IT OUT AND DO WHATEVER
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
CONVERSATIONS THEY NEED THAT.
AND FIGURE OUT THE FAIRNESS THAT
NEEDS TO THE PARKING FEES.
A SHARD BE EXCLUDED IN THAT THE
NEGOTIATION NOW WE'RE NOT SAYING
THAT WE'RE NOT SAYING IT
WOULDN'T WITH THE WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT THEY CAN TO GO
SHOULD THEY CAN'T BUT THEY
OBVIOUSLY NEED TO BE CONSCIOUS
THEM OF THE PRESIDENT.
OF THE CAMPUS OF THOSE ARE DOING
AND GO **** SHINS THAT WHATEVER
THEY AGREED TO HAS TO BE ALSO
SUPPORTED BY TWO IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE STUDENTS WOULD BE
ASKING FOR WHAT THEY'D ASK THE
STUDENTS TO GET.
IN -- IF --
AFTER NEGOTIATION --
IN NOT REALLY SAID THAT AND THEN
IT THE IN BUT FOR THE FACULTY
THAT'S UNIVERSE THIS UP IN OUR
SUBSIDIZING.
SO IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE OP
FARE SO IT'D BE MOST OF FAIR.
YOU KNOW THEY MAY GET THE MORE --
A PAY RAISE A TO MAKE A MAKE IT
UP UP BUT THAT THE LIST OF POP
PARKING IS CONCERNED THE BECAUSE
A SELF.
PARKING STRUCTURES OUT OR SELF
FUNDED.
AND THAT THEY'LL BE OBVIOUS ALL
OVER TWENTY YEARS OF THE AUDIO
SO HOW MUCH IT WOULD BE --
THAT THAT THAT THE WOULD BE.
EQUALLY --
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH --
PROJECTED THE PARKING SPACE
SPACES SO SO THAT THAT YOU TO BE
VERY.
CLEAN AND THE FAILURE UP BY NOT
ALLOWING OUR **** NO PARKING
FEES. FOR THE EMPLOYEES OR
FACULTY MEMBERS [inaudible]
I GUESS BUT ANYWAY THAT'S
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND AND
AND THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO BARGAIN
ON VARIOUS OTHER THINGS AND
WORKING CONDITIONS AS WELL --
BUT THE THING IS THAT --
IF YOU NOTICE UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THE PARKING FEES ARE
DIFFERENT AND DEPENDING ON THE
CAMPUS BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM ARE
NOT CHARGING A IN ONE CAMPUS
WILL A HUNDRED NINETY DOUBLES
CHARGING THREE HUNDRED TO
STUDENTS --
OFTENTIMES BUILT ON WHETHER NOT
THAT BUILDING NEW BUILDINGS AND
WHETHER THEY WANT STUDENTS TO BE
USED TO SUBSIDIZE THE CALTRANS
SAID A LOT OF THINGS THAT THAT
GO INTO IT.
AND WHILE WE COULD TALK ABOUT IT
OUR MAIN FOCUS IS.
THAT IS THE ISSUE OF FAIRNESS
NOW THAT STUDENTS SHOULD NOT BE
SUBSIDIZING FACULTY AND PARKING
THAT THERE SHOULD BE SOME
FAIRNESS IN TERMS OF OF THE FEES
THAT ARE CHARGED UNDERSTAND
THINKING QUE THANK YOU --
WE TAKE WE TAKE THAT AS A YEAH
YOU MAY TELL IT AS A CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME I VOTE THANK
YOU.
WE I I I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
THINK MISTER LEVINE DID IT OF
EXCELLENT JOB OF OUTLINING THE
THAT THE COST. TO THE TO THE
SYSTEM AND WHEN AND HOW YOU KNOW
IT WOULD BE DEFERRED BUT CSU IS
NOT HERE TO OPPOSE IT SO I'M
VERY MUCH.
IN FAVOR AND I AND I WOULD SAY
BEFORE WE VOTE IN MY EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
IT IS ALWAYS THE PARKING
SERVICES THAT ARE THE MOST
EFFICIENT THAT YOU CAN'T PARK
FOR TEN OR FIFTEEN MINUTES
WITHOUT COMING BACK AND HAVE IT
IF I NEED A TICKET ON YOUR THERE
ABOUT THAT IS.
BANK BUT IF YOU WANT SOMETHING
ELSE IT'S NOT USUALLY THAT QUICK.
WITH THAT EXCEPT THE MOTION.
SO THE MOVE BY MR PATTERSON.
SECOND BY MISTER REYES WHO
CHECKED --
MADAM SECRETARY VIEWED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY [inaudible]
KILEY LIVE LOW I PATTERSON
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
I THANK YOU. ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT AND THANK YOU TO MISTER RAY
IS FROM --
HIGH FOR PRESENTING.
I WILL GO THROUGH MISTER
PATTERSON.
THAT IS A FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN AB [inaudible]
FIVE OH FIVE RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU [inaudible]
UP.
AB.
FIVE OH FIVE IT WILL GIVE
STUDENTS ANOTHER OPTION TO
RECEIVE THEIR COURSE MATERIALS
AFFORDABLY AND IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES CAL GRANTS
AND PELL GRANTS TO ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION IN FEDERAL
STUDENT AID COMMISSION HOWEVER.
SOME ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
RECEIVE THEIR CAL GRANT OF THEIR
PELL GRANTS AFTER THE START OF
INSTRUCTION.
MANY THEY MAY NOT RECEIVE THEIR
ASSISTANCE FOR COSTLY TEXT BOOKS
UNTIL WEEKS AFTER THIS SEMESTER
BEGINS.
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC FOR STUDENTS
WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET FOR REQUIRED READING AN
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS. FOR
THEIR AND ROLLED CLASSES AB FIVE
OH FIVE SEEKS TO AID THE
STUDENTS BY REQUIRING THE
UNIVERSITIES TO EXTEND A LINE OF
CREDIT TO THEM. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF PURCHASING REQUIRED BOOKS AND
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS AT THE
CAMPUS BOOKSTORE AT THE START OF
THE ACADEMIC SEMESTER.
OR TERM AND UNTIL ONE DAY BEFORE
THE INSTITUTIONS CENSUS DATE FOR
THAT ACADEMIC SEMESTER OR TERM.
THE BOOKSTORE WOULD THEN REPORT
BACK TO THE UNIVERSITY THE
AMOUNT OF THE CREDIT USED BY THE
STUDENTS SO IT CAN BE CREDITED
AGAINST.
THEIR INCOMING GRANT FUNDS. FOR
EXAMPLE IF A STUDENT IT IS SET
TO RECEIVE FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR ONE SEMESTER.
AND THEY USED THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS THAT THE BOOKSTORE WILL
SUBSEQUENTLY CVS.
THREE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED A
FURTHER MORE THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS ALREADY REQUIRE
INSTITUTIONS TO ENSURE THE PELL
GRANT RECIPIENTS.
HAVE FUNDING RESOURCES
ACCESSIBLE TO THEM IN ORDER TO
OBTAIN BOOKS AND SUPPLIES WITHIN
THE FIRST SEVEN DAYS.
OF THE TERM AB FIVE OH FIVE
SIMPLY IS MIRRORING THIS FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT BY EXPANDING IT. TO
ANY STUDENT RECEIVING A CAL
GRANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENTS GET THEIR SUPPLIES.
ON TIME.
TODAY I HAVE A WITH MEDIA ERIN
BEARD LEAD HE IS --
ACRE THE CURRENT STUDENT AT READ
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND ABOUT
A PRESIDENT THEIR ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS --
CLUB JEFF WHALEN IS HERE AS WELL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
OF COLLEGE BOOKSTORES TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
ERIN FEAR SAYING LET.
I AM A COMMUNICATIONS MAJOR AT
READ THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IS SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
STUDENTS FROM ALL SOCIO ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS.
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND SOCIAL MOBILITY CAL GRANTS
ARE SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH THE MOST FINANCIAL NEED
WITH THE MEANS TO AFFORD TUITION
AND TEXTBOOKS.
AS A LOW INCOME AND AS A FIRST
GENERATION STUDENT HAVING ACCESS
TO CAL GRANT IS ESSENTIAL FOR ME.
TO ATTEND COLLEGE UNFORTUNATELY
MY EXPERIENCE AS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT HAS SHOWN ME.
THE DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS OF NOT
RECEIVING FINANCIAL AID ON TIME.
IN ORDER TO COMPENSATE FOR THE
DELAY OTHER MIDDLE COURSES ON
MIKE ON ME COMPLETING MY
EDUCATION.
I TOOK EIGHTEEN UNITS ONE
SEMESTER THE TOTAL COST OF THE
BOOKS THAT SEMESTER WAS SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
UP FOR MOST STUDENTS SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS IS ONE MONTH'S RENT FOR
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BUYING
ENOUGH GROCERS.
BECAUSE OF MY FIND BECAUSE MY
FINANCIAL IT HAD NOT RIGHT ON
TIME I WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PURCHASING THE BOOKS.
WITH THE EARNINGS FROM MY PART
TIME MINIMUM WAGE JOB.
AND EVEN AFTER CONSERVING AS
MUCH MONEY --
AS MUCH MONEY FROM MY SAVINGS AS
I COULD TOWARDS MY BOOKS I COULD
NOT AFFORD.
THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR ONLINE ACCESS CODE. FOR
MY MATH CLASS THE CODE WAS
NECESSARY TO TAKE THE QUIZZES
FOR THE CLASS AND BECAUSE I
MISSED THE FIRST TWO QUIZZES I
WAS DROPPED FROM THE CLASS.
AT TWO DAYS AFTER I WAS DROPPED
IN THE CLASS --
AND FOURTEEN DAYS AFTER THE
FIRST DAY OF INSTRUCTION MY CAL
GRANT WAS DISTRIBUTED.
ARE THERE PLENTY MORE STORIES
LIKE MINE ACROSS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND IT'S TIME
THAT WE SHIP POLICIES THAT
INVEST IN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS.
AND I THINK THAT POLICIES LIKE
AB FIVE A FIVE DO JUST THAT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN MY NAME IS JEFF WHELAN
HI MANAGE THE PIRATES BOOKSTORE
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE AS WELL
AS MANAGING THE MANZANITA
BOOKSTORE AT COLUMBIA COLLEGE
WERE PART OF THE SEMI COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
I AM ALSO ON THE BOARD FOR THE
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGE STORES
AND WE REPRESENT.
INSTITUTIONALLY RUN BOOKSTORES
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE YOU SEE
CSU SYSTEM UP AND DOWN THE STATE
EVEN IN THE ARIZONA NEVADA --
SO WHEN I WOULD I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE
THIS IS ACTUALLY QUITE EXCITING
TO BE PART OF THE PROCESS OF
ACTUALLY SEEING A BILL THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON STUDENTS.
AND I KNOW THIS FIRST HAND.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES
THAT WE'VE HAD STUDENTS WALKING
TO THE BOOKSTORE AND SAY HEY YOU
KNOW WHAT I NEED MY BOOKS.
I DON'T HAVE MY FUNDS DISBURSED
YET WHAT CAN I DO AND FROM MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE IN MY STAFF
TALKING TO ME.
WE JUST KIND OF SHRUG OUR
SHOULDERS AND GOLD.
I DON'T KNOW.
AND IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE VERY
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE THE
STUDENTS HONORED US.
WE HAVE A STUDENT RIGHT HERE
THAT JUST TESTIFIED --
ONE THING I DID DO IS I TALKED
TO PAY HE FITS C IS OUR
DIRECTOR OF FINANCIAL SERVICES
AT MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE.
AND SHE DID SAY YES THERE IS A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF PELL GRANTS
RECIPIENTS THAT.
DO HAVE ISSUES MAINLY BECAUSE OF
THE APPLICATIONS BUT IT IS
ACTUALLY A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE.
BUT CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS HAVE
SEEM TO HAVE THE BIGGER ISSUE AS
FAR AS HAVING FUNDS DISPERSED --
AT A REASONABLE TIME SO THAT
THEY CAN PURCHASE COURSE
MATERIALS AND EVEN SUPPLIES.
I NEEDED.
ALL RIGHT AT SHE GAVE ME THE
NUMBER OF EIGHTY EIGHT FOR THE
LAST SPRING OF CAL GRANT --
RECIPIENTS THAT UNFORTUNATELY
HAD DISBURSEMENTS DELAY NOW
THAT'S NOT A LARGE NUMBER --
COMPARED TO THE ENROLLMENT OF
OUR SCHOOL BUT FOR THOSE EIGHTY
EIGHT STUDENTS THAT MEANS A LOT --
SO THE OTHER THING THAT IS --
AS I'VE TALKED --
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON'S
OFFICE --
THE SOMEBODY FROM SERVICE OFFICE
CALLED ME RECENTLY.
IS THERE IS A HUGE CONCERN OVER
THE COST OF SETTING THIS PROGRAM
UP.
AND I CAN TALK FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT COST WOULD BE.
WE HAVE POINTED POINT OF SALE
SYSTEMS RIGHT NOW THAT HANDLE
BILLING WE BILL WE ALLOW YOUR P.
AND S. STUDENTS WE ALLOW
VETERANS WE ALLOW CAL GRANT --
CAO WORK STUDENTS TO ALL COME
AND PURCHASE BOOKS AND WE CHARGE.
THE BOOKS AGAINST AN ACCOUNT
FROM A VOUCHER THAT WAS SET UP.
AND WE ARE ABLE TO BUILD
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS VERY
EASILY THIS IS ALREADY SET UP.
SO IF THERE'S ANY CONCERNED OVER
THE COST --
OF SETTING UP A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS.
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW I HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT THAT IS --
THE QUESTION ALSO CAME ABOUT
WHERE THERE ARE COMPANIES OUT
THERE LIKE FALL LET BARNES AND
NOBLE THAT WILL LEASE THE
BOOKSTORE.
HOW ABOUT THEM I UNFORTUNATELY
CAN'T SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THEM BUT
I DO HAVE A FRIEND?
I SUSAN LUCCI WHO --
WORKS OUT OF THE MOUNT SAN
ANTONIO I CALLED HER UP TALK TO
HER AND AGAIN SHE ALSO FROM THE
BARNES AND NOBLE SIDE.
THEIR SYSTEM IS SET UP TO DO
BILLING THIS IS JUST ANOTHER.
TAKES.
YOU KNOW THE COST WOULD BE
HOWEVER LONG IT TAKES TO TYPE IN.
A NEW DEPARTMENT I MEAN SO.
THANK YOU YOU'RE VERY WELCOME
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER PATTERSON IT
UP CLOSE VERY QUICKLY --
WITH A LITTLE COMMENT ABOUT THAT.
SOME OPPOSITION THE DID COME IN
RATHER UP LATE AND I JUST WANTED
TO EXPLAIN.
AT FIRST I UNDERSTAND MANY
STUDENTS PREFER PURCHASING THE
BOOKS AND SUPPLIES ONLINE AB
FIVE OH FIVE IN NO WAY.
IS AIMING TO TAKE THAT OPTION
AWAY FROM STUDENTS AT ALL RATHER
AB FIVE OH FIVE IS PROVIDING A
BACKUP OPTION.
ONLY IF STUDENTS WANT TO CHOOSE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT FOR
STUDENTS TO PURCHASE BOOKS WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS.
AT HAND --
STUDENTS TO PURCHASE BOOKS --
THROUGH AMAZON OR SOME OTHER
SOURCE THAT'S ALWAYS OPEN TO
THEM TO DO WHAT THEY WOULD LIKE
TO DO AB FIVE A FIVE IS NOT
FORCING STUDENTS. TO PURCHASE
BOOKS AT THE BOOKSTORE.
AS THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE ENTIRE
FOR STUDENTS THE SECOND.
OPPOSITION THAT WAS BROUGHT IN
LATE -- THE
POINT AT THE FEDERAL REGULATION
ALREADY REQUIRE INSTITUTIONSTO
PROVIDE STUDENTS ACCESS TO THEIR
FINANCIAL AID BEGINNING SEMESTER
PURCHASE BOOKS AND SUPPLIES.
WELL THE OPPOSITION MENTION THE
FACT THAT EIGHTY FIVE A FIVE
DUPLICATES.
EXISTING RETIREMENT AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER AB FIVE OH
FIVE DOES NOT GAME TO DUPLICATE
BUT RATHER TO EXPAND THIS --
FRONT TO CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS SO
MEMBERS I ASK --
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THAT
THE BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHAT IT THANK THE EITHER BRING
THE BILLBOARD I SUPPORTED THIS
INNOVATIVE IDEA LAST YEAR AND I
SUPPORTED AGAIN THIS YEAR?
WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER GAVE
ROLE AS SECOND BY --
MISTER CHOI MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
AM BLOOM.
I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY [inaudible]
KILEY.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I'D SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER ALL RIGHT.
I THANK EVERYBODY.
OUT LEAVE IT OPEN --
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO JUST.
WONDERING.
MR SANTIAGO WOULD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO FIRST OR WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TO GO FIRST.
YEAH
[inaudible] NINE OKAY ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT THE A. B. OF FIVE
NINETY FIVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHAIRPERSON MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
TODAY I PRESENT AB FIVE NINETY
FIVE AB FIVE NINETY FIVE WOULD
CREATE A PATH. TO ALLOW
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TO ENTER.
ALLIED HOW ANOTHER PRINTER SHIP.
AND INTERNSHIP TRAINING PROGRAMS.
WITHOUT HAVING TO ENROLL IN THE
DOCK A PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OFFER A WIDE ARRAY OF PROGRAMS
THE REQUIRE PARTICIPATION IN
APPRENTICESHIP --
ENTRENCHED INTERNSHIP PROGRAMS.
HOWEVER MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO HAVE.
A VALID SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
WHICH PREVENTS UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
DHAKA.
ENTRY IN THESE PROGRAMS.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
ESTIMATED ESTIMATES THAT
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS MAKE UP.
505-000-0270 THOUSAND OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE POPULATION.
THE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
REQUIREMENT IS IMPOSSIBLE
OBSTACLE FRIEND DOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
DR.
THE IRS ISSUES INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS TO
INDIVIDUALS ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
A U. S. TAXPAYER IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER.
BUT WHO DO NOT HAVE.
AND ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO OBTAIN A
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
THE I. T. I. N. S. ARE NOT AND
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT TOOL.
AND NOT SHARING APPLICANTS
PRIVATE INFORMATION IS NECESSARY
FOR INSURANCE TAX COMPLIANCE.
AB FIVE NINETY FIVE WOULD ALLOW
USING THE INDIVIDUAL I. T. I. N.
IN LIEU OF A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT.
IS SENT THE A MOST GATHER.
COUNSELOR AT EL CAMINO COLLEGE.
CHRISTOPHER'S SIGNED CHET'S
POLICY FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS.
AND STEPHANIE GOLDMAN EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR.
AT THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OKAY GO AHEAD OKAY AT GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY --
AGAIN MY NAME IS CYNTHIA MUSCAT
MACAU SIR --
IN TORRANCE CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO SUPPORT AB.
FIVE NINETY FIVE WHICH WILL
ALLOW UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF DHAKA STATUS TO
THE I. T. A NUMBER IN LIEU OF
ASSOCIATE CARRY NUMBER ON THERE
ARE MANY ACADEMIC PROGRAMS WITH
IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
THAT IN MANY CASES HAVE A FILL
WORK EXPERIENCE APPRENTICESHIP
COMPONENTS AND SOMETIMES
INTERNSHIPS AS WELL AS CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE IS REQUIRED.
AB FIVE NINETY FIVE WILL ALLOW
STUDENTS TO APPLY FOR PROGRAMS
THAT OFTEN --
REQUIRES SPECIALIZED TRAINING AS
MENTIONED AND SOME CASES ON JOB
EXPERIENCE --
SINCE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HALTED ALL NEW DOC OUT
APPLICATIONS I AS A COUNSELOR
AND SEEING A WHOLE NEW
GENERATION OF STUDENTS THAT'S
COMING TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ARE VERY MUCH INTERESTED IN
APPLYING FOR MANY OF OUR ALLY
PROGRAMS SUCH AS NURSING
RESPIRATORY CARE RAT TECH WHO
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T TAKE THE
PREREQUISITES FOR THESE PROGRAMS
BUT WHEN IT COMES TIME TO APPLY
TO THE ACTUAL PROGRAM.
THEY ARE AND ABLE TO DO SO
BECAUSE THEY LACK OF SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER.
ON AB FIVE NINETY FIVE WOULD
ALLOW A NEW GENERATION OF
STUDENTS TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR ALL
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS OFFERED
OFFERED THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE BECAUSE SYSTEM.
REGARDLESS OF THE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER OR IMMIGRATION.
BECAUSE RESPONSES WHICH ARE THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND ALSO REPRESENTING OUR
YOUTH COALITION THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM NETWORK WHICH IS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TWENTY
COLLEGES TO CEASE USING UC'S
WHILE WE ARE STRONG SUPPORTER
THIS BILL MOST OF ARE COMPLETELY
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION HAPPENS
TO BE AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEVEL.
AND THIS BILL ACT IT WOULDJUST
A A BIG NEW THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW A LOT OF OUR FOLKS
THAT DO WANT TO APPLY THESE
PROGRAMS DO HAVE.
TROUBLE BECAUSE OF THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT THIS.
I AT THE I. T. I. TEN NUMBER
WILL BE VERY BENEFICIAL FOR THE
MINERAL TO THESE PROGRAMS FOR
THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
AND SEVEN GOLDMEN HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES AT
PROUD SMARTER THAN SPROUT
SPONSORS.
ANY OF THE SUPPOSED TO WITNESSES
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ADJUSTING SILICON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
A DRY RIVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
RYM MACLAINE AND WE HAVE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA SEVENTY
TWO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
AND SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY OTHER IF NOT ANY
OPPOSING NOT WITNESSES
[inaudible]
NOBODY [inaudible]
BARBARA [inaudible]
NOW. TO OUR A COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
OKAY.
MOVED AND SECONDED THAT.
WE HAD THEM.
AS THE REMOTE MURATSUCHI THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I THANK YOU RIGHT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE A COMMONSENSE
PROPOSAL.
AND THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE SOME
FROM TORRANCE ADVOCATING THIS.
SEALS THE DEAL SO [inaudible]
THE WARRIORS [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
OKAY THE MOVE THEN THE SECOND IT.
YES FREE RIVAL.
ALL RIGHT GO HEAD TO CONNECT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
MATTEUCCI MATTEUCCI AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY [inaudible]
KILEY.
LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER II.
OKAY A TWO ZERO PASSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CONGRATULATIONS [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
BEFORE WE I CAN BE HELPFUL I
DON'T KNOW [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE OPEN THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
I AM.
ITEM FOR A. B..
THREE EIGHT ONE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I KILEY.
PATTERSON [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible] NINE ZERO
MISSION WAS TO HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WE'RE WAITING.
FOR AUTHORED.
WE ARE ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
ONE AB.
TWO MISTER SANTIAGO.
I THINK IT WAS CHAIR WE WANT TO
START OFF WITH AB THREE FIFTY
SIX IF THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] THREE
YES IT WILL BE BRIEF ON THIS --
ONE AB THREE FIFTY SIX WOULD
AUTHORIZE A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
THE LOSS AND JUST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT USE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT.
IN CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
EXCEEDING ONE MILLION DOLLARS
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
WITH THIS I HAVE ONE WITNESS WHO
ALSO BE BRIEF --
THE CHANCE OF LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
IT'S NOT VERY MUCH --
MISTER CHAIR HONORABLE MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
GOT COMMITTEE OF THE JANICE
VOTERS OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMITTEE CALLS DISTRICT.
I VOTED ON FOUR SEPARATE
OCCASIONS AFFIRMATIVELY SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ONE TO SUPPORT THE
MODERNIZATION OF FACILITIES AND
LEARN IMPROVEMENTS.
AT EACH OF OUR NINE COLLEGES AT
LA CCD THE LAST BALLOT MEASURE
PASSED AT 76%.
WE RECENTLY BEGAN THE PROCESS
FOR ACTING FOR SIMPLE ROUTINE
PROJECTS WERE TIMELINESS.
AND PROJECT COMPLETION ARE
CRITICAL LA CCD SEES BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT AS ANOTHER TOOL THAT
WE CAN USE UNDER THE RIGHT
CIRCUMSTANCES. TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING THE MOST.
OR BEST VALUE FOR THE PRECIOUS
DOLLARS THAT OUR PUBLIC A GIVES
US FOR OVER TEN YEARS. FOR THE
NEXT TEN YEARS LA SEE CITY WILL
BE CONTRACTING CLOSE TO FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS FROM MUCH THE TO
PROJECTS LIKE THE NEW CHAVEZ
BUILDING AT LOS ANGELES CITY
COLLEGE WHICH HOUSES.
STUDENT SERVICES AT EAST LA
COLLEGE THE NEW.
NURSING ALLIED HEALTH FACILITY
AND THAT LOS ANGELES PIERCE
COLLEGE THE AGRICULTURAL
EDUCATION CENTER.
WHICH PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE TRAINING
SUPPORT LOS ANGELES COUNTIES
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED MILLION
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY.
BUT BEST PIPER KERMAN ALSO IS
CRITICAL FOR OTHER PROJECTS SUCH
AS THE ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES TO OUR
AGENT INFRASTRUCTURE AT OUR
COLLEGES LOS ANGELES TRADE
TECHNICAL COLLEGE FOR EXAMPLE IS.
NINETY FOUR YEARS OLD THESE
IMPROVEMENTS WILL INCLUDE STORM
WATER CAPTURE AND RETENTION
SYSTEMS ABA UPGRADES AND
TECHNOLOGY.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT THIS BEST
PIPER KERMAN HAS YET BEEN
UTILIZED AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS THE LA U. S. THE IN A
PILOT BASIS WE'RE SEEKING THE
SAME PROVISION.
DURING THIS TIME PERIOD THE COST
GOING DOWN HAVE BEEN DECREASED
TREMENDOUS VALUE REASONS I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
AGAIN FRANCISCO TO THE US CHANCE
OF THE LOS ANGELES COMMITTEE
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT.
RANMA CLEANER THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
WEEK WEEK WE HAD A MOTION BY
MISTER LEVINE A SECOND BY MR
GABRIEL --
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
SANTIAGO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOOK THANK YOU MISTER AND I
THINK AGAIN WILL SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION --
I'VE SEEN IT WORK SUCCESSFULLY
BOTH IN THE UC SYSTEM AND FOR LA
U. S. D. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING HOW.
LA COMMUNITY COLLEGE I CAN
IMPLEMENT BEST VALUE.
SO WE HAD A MOTION.
AND A SECOND.
A MATTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE BOOK.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI AYE MATTEUCCI MURATSUCHI I
BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY.
DALY I KILEY.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW FLOW I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER HI. TEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW WILL GO ON TO ITEM ONE A. B..
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WELCOME TO MISTER MCCARTY.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
A WORKING WITH US OVER LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
I TO MAKE SURE THAT AB NINETEEN
WAS IMPLEMENTED WHICH GAVE THE
FIRST TIME FULL TIME --
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THIS YEAR
WE COME BACK AND WE WANT TO PUSH
FOR A SECOND YEAR HI AND NOT
ONLY THAT BUT WE WANTED TO ANY
STUDENT WHO GOES FULL TIME.
A BUT THERE'S MORE THAT --
THE UNDERLYING THIS ISSUE IS
ALSO THE ABILITY TO INCREASE
STUDENT SUCCESS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT WHEN A STUDENT GOES FULL
TIME TO SCHOOL.
THEIR STUDENT SUCCESS NUMBERS GO
UP UP SUBSTANTIALLY WE ESTIMATED
WE STARTED A. B. NINETEEN THAT
WOULD BE 6270% IN STUDENT
SUCCESS.
SOME OF THE COURTS LIKE THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT HAS SHOWN US UP 283%
SUCCESS RATE AND PERSISTENCE
NUMBERS FROM THE FIRST.
COHORT OF AB NINETEEN TO THE
SECOND YEAR IN EXTREMELY
VALUABLE --
STEP BOARD IN MAKING EDUCATION
DEBT FREE --
AND HELP IN THE PUSH FOR STUDENT
SUCCESS --
WHAT THE SAME TIME USING
EXISTING PROGRAMS OFF FOR A TO
HELP A STUDENT FINANCIALLY WITH
NON ON TUITION COST --
AS YOU KNOW THE BILL HAS SEVERAL
PARTS TO IT IT'S FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IT'S THE WRAPAROUND
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT MAKES A
STUDENTS SUCCESSFUL.
IT IS THE ABILITY IT IS THE
ABILITY EACH EACH STUDENT TO
SIGN UP FOR THE FAST SUPPORT SO
THEY CAN GET THEIR CAL GRANT.
AND PELL GRANTS --
AND PARTICIPATION THE GUIDED
PATHWAYS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I WOULD HAND IT OF ONE
A JOINT AUTHORS MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
MISTER SANTIAGO --
PRETTY MUCH LAID OUT THERE BUT
IT'S NOT FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
WEEK WE IMPLEMENTED THIS BILL
LAST YEAR IN THE BUDGET WAS
PASSED TWO YEARS AGO AND THIS IS
A LOGICAL EXTENSION.
HOW YOU LOOK ABOUT THE DEBATE IT
AS FAR AS FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE?
IT MAY NOT MAKE THE MOST SENSE
FOR ALL THREE SEGMENTS WE'D LIKE
TO DO IT BUT IT'S PROBABLY AN
AVOID UNAFFORDABLE WITH.
MULTI BILLIONS --
NEEDED TO TO DO THAT THIS ONE IS
VERY AFFORDABLE --
AND YOU CAN YOU CAN GET THE
BIGGEST BANG SIDE WITH THE FIRST
YEAR IT'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
AND WE KNOW THAT WE NEED MORE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN COLLEGE WE KNOW
THAT OUR ECONOMY --
DICTATES THE MORE PEOPLE WITH
ADVANCED DEGREES CERTIFICATES
DEGREES IN GENERAL AND RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT STUDENTS TO ENROLL.
FULL TIME ARE MORE LIKELY.
TO TRANSPORT OR COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE CERTIFICATE PROGRAM CAN
BE SUCCESSFUL SO WE NEED THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR THE FUTURE OF
OUR ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT WORKS FOR THEM SO THEY
CAN CERTAINLY HELP THE FAMILIES
AND GET A GOOD PAYING JOB AT
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND THEN --
LASTLY AS MR SANTIAGO NOTED WE
ARE WORKING THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS CONCURRENTLY DEFINE US
LIGHT EXTENSION OF WHAT'S IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
THE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WOULD HAVE A SECOND TIER FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES PEOPLE GO TO
COMMUNICATE ALL BEEN THERE
EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN THEY GO
WORK FOR A COUPLE YEARS MAYBE
JOINED THE SERVICE OR SO FORTH.
COME BACK AND THEN WANT TO GO
OUT AGAIN SO UNDER THE PROPOSAL --
THEY WOULDN'T BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT FOR THE FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BECAUSE THERE WAS NOT
THEIR FIRST TIME AND ROLLING SO
AT THIS WOULD SAY THAT ANYBODY.
WHO'S GOING FULL TIME WOULD GET --
A FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT IT
STILL WOULD HAVE A TWO YEAR CAP
SO WE THINK THIS MAKES SENSE
THAT ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMITTEE BECAUSE ON ONE POINT
FIRST I WANT TO THANK.
MISTER SANTIAGO AND MISS MCCARTY
FORD REDUCING ASSEMBLY BILL TO
IT IS MADE A WORLD OF DIFFERENCE
FOR STUDENTS WHO AS YOU KNOW THE
MOST THAT AMONGST THE MOST
HIDEOUS.
AT THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF HOW THIS PROGRAM HAS
INDEED WORK FROM A GROUND LEVEL
WE HAVE INDEED SEEN.
A 54% INCREASE IN DIRECT FULL
TIME ENTRANCE FROM THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AS A RESULT OF THE COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM.
THAT 80% FALL THE FALL
PERSISTENCE RATES WHICH FAR
EXCEEDS THOSE PERSONS WHO ARE
NOT PART OF THE PROMISE PROGRAM
AND THE PROGRAM'S REALLY DOUBLE
THE NUMBER STUDENTS COMPLETING
TRANSFER LEVEL ENGLISH.
AND TRANSFER LEVEL MATH IN THE
FIRST ACADEMIC YEAR AND FINALLY
THE CURRENT QUARTER STUDENTS OF
OVER FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS.
IS 87% LATINO AND 80% 81% OF LOW
INCOME SO THEY ONLY COLLEGE
PROMISE BILLS ON THE LEGACY IN A
LANDMARK LEGISLATION.
OF ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN HAS
ENABLED US TO DISTRIBUTE JUST A
RESOURCE TO STUDENTS INCLUDING
PAT TEXTBOOK CUT TRANSIT PASSES
AND OTHER KINDS OF FOOD
ASSISTANCE.
AND AS I MENTIONED OF THE EARLY
RESULTS ARE ABSOLUTELY TERRIFIC
AT PORTENDS A VERY SOLID FUTURE
TO STUDENTS. FOR MONTHS THE THE
MOST UNDER RESOURCE I HAVE WITH
ME ONE OF THE PROVIDE TESTIMONY
JORGE ACOSTA HE'S A STUDENT AT
LOS ANGELES.
HARBOR COLLEGE IN A PARTICIPANT
IN THE LOS ANGELES COLORS
PROMISED PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT
TO GIVE US THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND THE CHAIRMAN SELF.
TAUGHT ME TO SPEAK MY ON A
MEASURE MY STORY.
MY NAME IS FOR TACKLE STUFF I AM
A SOPHOMORE LOS ANGELES HARBOR
COLLEGE.
MAJORING IN ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE.
WHEN MY PARENTS CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY THIRTY YEARS AGO THE
ONLY HAD FIVE DOLLARS IN THEIR
POCKET?
AND THE CLUE AND THE CLOTHES ON
THEIR BACK.
THEY WERE PURSUE THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
AND WANT TO BUILD A BETTER LIFE
AND SELF.
THEY WORKING ANY JOB THEY COULD
FIND FOR LONG HOURS THE WORK
EVERY DAY EVENTUALLY BECOMING US
CITIZENS OPENING THEIR OWN
BUSINESS AND ACHIEVING THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
BOTH TO THEIR HARD WORK BUILD A
BETTER LIFE MY SIBLINGS AND ME.
MY PARENTS TAUGHT ME THE VALUE
OF HARD WORK DISCIPLINE AND
EDUCATION.
THEY WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY SO I
CAN HAVE A GOOD LIFE AND PURSUE
MY DREAM.
I AM NINETEEN YEARS OLD.
AND I'M THE FIRST IN MY FAMILY
TO PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION.
AT THE FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT.
I'VE HAD MY CHALLENGES PRODUCTS
ALSO SUCCESS.
I MOSTLY COLLEGE PROMISE STUDENT.
I'VE BEEN GIVEN THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION
THINGS TO THE PROMISE TO STAY
MADE TO STUDENTS.
HELP ME AND MANY OTHERS BUILD A
FOUNDATION FOR SUCCESS AND
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AS THE FRESHMAN I DON'T KNOW
MUCH ABOUT COLLEGE AND HOW TO
SUCCEED.
AFTER BROWN MYSELF STRUGGLING
WITH ASSIGNMENTS APPLICATIONS
AND OTHER FORMS.
I WANTED TO GIVE UP AND DROP OUT.
THE COLLEGE PROMISE HELP ME GET
BACK ON MY FEET BY PROVIDING
WORKSHOPS AND MENTORS.
THE ANY STUDENT AT THE RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID AND HAVING MY HOPE
MY TO HARD WORKING PARENTS PAY
OUT OF POCKET STRESSED ME OUT
EVERY EVERY DAY.
BUT THE PROMISE PROGRAM HELPED
ME TREMENDOUSLY.
WITH OTHER TUITION HELP I
WOULDN'T BE A FULL TIME STUDENT
AS I WOULD HAVE TO WORK FULL
TIME IN ORDER TO PAY FOR MY
EDUCATION.
MY PARENTS ON ONLY SUPPORTING ME.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO PAYING OUT OF
POCKET MY SIBLINGS AS WELL.
WHEN I SAY THIS PROGRAM IS LIKE
CHANGING I MEAN IT?
I CAN BE A FULL TIME STUDENT
FOCUS ON MY STUDIES AND NOT
WORRY ABOUT HOW MY PARENTS AND I
GOING TO PAY FOR MY EDUCATION.
WITH ALL THIS HELP THIS PROGRAM
HAS PROVIDED ME I SUCCEEDED MY
FIRST YEAR JOINT CLOTH
EVENTUALLY BECOMING VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE HARVARD
ADVANTAGE LEADERSHIP CLUB.
AS VICE PRESIDENT I WAS PRESENT
WITH OPPORTUNITIES TO SIT DOWN
WITH MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI AND THE
STAFF ON HOW MYSELF AND OTHERS
CAN IMPROVE THE PROGRAM.
I DISCUSS IDEAS ON HOW TO HELP
FUTURE STUDENTS AND THE PROGRAM
MOVING FORWARD.
I WANTED MORE STUDENTS TO HAVE
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY AND THE
PROGRAM HAS THEIR BACKS.
BEING A PIONEER OF THE PROGRAM I
WANT A FUTURE STUDENTS TO KNOW
THEY CAN SUCCEED NO MATTER THE
SITUATION.
I BEGAN TO SHARE MY STORYWITH
STUDENTS AND MY COMMUNITY ON HOW
AND HOW I WAS ABLE ON I WAS ABLE
TO OVERCOME CHALLENGES AND HOW
THE COLLEGE PROMISED HELP ME.
I CHIEF MICHAEL THE TRANSFERRING
AND GRADUATING.
THIS PROMISE THAT THE STATE HAS
MADE WITH ME HAS CHANGED MY
FAMILY'S LIFE AND FUTURE.
I'M GRATEFUL TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
LOS ANGELES HARBOR COLLEGE AND
THE LOSS I JUST COMMUTER COLLEGE
DISTRICT FOR BELIEVING N ME
EFFORTS OPPORTUNITY.
AS MY JOURNEY HARPER COMES TO AN
END.
ANOTHER JOURNEY BEGINS.
THIS SPRING I WILL BE GRADUATING
WITH THE AT T. AND
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE TO
EIGHT DEGREES AND SOCIAL AND
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE AND ARTS IN
HUMANITIES.
MY HEART WORK WILL BE PAYING OFF
THIS FALL AS I WILL BE
TRANSFERRED TO CALVET DOMINGUEZ
HILLS.
OR PLANT WHERE I WILL CONTINUE
MY EDUCATION A LAW AND MINOR
POLITICAL SCIENCE.
ALSO CONTINUE TO MAKE AN IMPACT
IN MY IN THE SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY.
I PLAN TO BECOME A CRIMINAL
LAWYER AND SORRY NONPROFIT THAT
WILL FOCUS ON HELPING STUDENTS
ACHIEVE SUCCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THE COLLEGE PROMISE AS GIVING AS
CAN BE THE MOST POWERFUL TOOL
WHICH EDUCATION.
THIS TO ALLOW ME TO IMPACT LIVES
AND WILL HELP ME TO IMPACT MANY
MORE.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE FOOT
HEALED THE ENDS A KERN FOR ALL.
TO SAN DIEGO AND SAN FRANCISCO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
AS WELL AS THE LOS ANGELES
COLLEGE FACULTY GUILD IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY
AND THOSE OF YOU ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
AS WELL LOOK FOR OPTIONS TO FUND
THIS THANK YOU.
BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MANDY OF SAN JOSE EVERGREEN CAM
COMING ACROSS AS A VERY MUCH THE
SPORT ALSO WANT TO THANK --
THE CALL THIS VERY MUCH.
PERSONALLY COULD ALSO WITH A SHY
YOUR ENTRY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES CITY MAYOR --
ERICA CITY IN SUPPORT.
STILL SHE WAS SAKE REPRESENTING
SANTA MONICA COLLEGE LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE IN SOUTH
ORANGE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT CALLED SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE GOLDEN
AT THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT
OF THIS BILL AND ESPECIALLY THE
MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS THE ONLY
A SUGGESTION WE'D LIKE TO MAKE
IS HAVE IT IS EXTEND TO OUR PART
TIME STUDENTS ARE OFTEN OUR MOST
MEDIA STUDENTS AND MUST WORK
LIKE A SCHOOL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
WHICH CUSTOMERS SHOULD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I SUPPORTED.
TO AB NINETEEN AND TO AND HI
[inaudible]
SUPPORT --
AND CONCEPT WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING MY ONLY CONCERN IS HOW
WE'RE GONNA PAY FOR IT AND I I
APPRECIATE.
TO OF MISTER MCCARTY BEING HERE
AS WE BOTH SIT ON THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
ARM.
MY MY FIRST QUESTION IS --
GAG GIVEN THAT BOTH THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND K.
THROUGH TWELVE OR UNDER PROP
NINETY EIGHT TO HAVE WITH THIS --
AFFECTED PROP NINETY FUNDING FOR
K. TWELVE SCHOOLS.
WELL THE THE THE TENANTS OF THIS --
PROPOSAL THE EXTENT EXTENSION
FOR THE SECOND YEAR IS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET.
SO TO DO THE THE OUT ON THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING WHICH IS WHICH
IS IN THE BILL IN THE AMENDMENTS.
WOULD COST ANOTHER TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS SO THERE ARE
THERE ARE TWO THINGS ONE WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT.
OUR AND GET SOME ROBUST --
TAX PAYMENT THE STATE COPPER
SPECIALLY PEOPLE FILING LATER
THAT WE WILL HAVE A MAY REVISE
WITH.
ADDITIONAL PROP NINETY EIGHT
RESOURCES AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE HAVE.
COMMITTEE CALLED SPLIT 11% WHAT
HAVE YOU.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO
FUNDED THROUGH THAT --
ABSENT THAT OR IF WORST CASE
SCENARIO.
IF THE I LIKE THE ELOISE TALKING
ABOUT WE HAVE A DAY THAT HAD A
DECREASE IN PROP --
NINETY EIGHT APPROPRIATION IN
THE MAY REVISED.
YOUR NON EVERYTHING'S IN ALL
BETS ARE OFF A LOT TO RE
EVALUATE --
THE THE THE EXPANSION.
IN THIS BILL AS WELL AS OTHER
THINGS AS WELL SO OUT YOU KNOW
THIS IS ALL CONTINGENT UPON THE
FINAL ACTION THE BUDGET AND SOME
[inaudible]
HI -- ****
THAT AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A POLICY COMMITTEE
RATHER THAN THE PHYSICAL
COMMITTEE --
BUT YEAH THE MAIN AND STOPPING
THIS CHAIRMAN IF IF --
IF I MADELINE HERE BUT WE YOU
KNOW.
AS AS MISTER MCCARTY NIGHT ALL
ARE ALSO INVOLVED IN THE IN THE
PROCESS ON A YOU KNOW WOULD GET
GETTING CALIFORNIA AT FROM FORTY
FIRST TWELVE SCHOOLS AND SO. FOR
ME PERSONALLY I CAN CONCERNED --
YOU KNOW THAT --
WHILE WE WOULD ALL LOVE FREE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE --
THAT -- WE
WE ARE --
DEALING IN THE REAL WORLD OF OF
LIMITED RESOURCES FOR ALL THE
GROUP OF THE GREAT THINGS YOU
WANT TO DO AND SO.
WHAT YEAH?
THE MAN MISTER YES I THINK I
WOULD SAY IS IT'S NOT COMING OUT
OF THE KEY TO TOLL POT.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY BUT IN A HIGH
LEVEL POINT NINETY IT'S BROKEN
DOWN AS AN 11% OF IT GOES TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SO THAT'S THAT MONEY COULD BE
USED ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
THE QUESTION BEFORE US IS AND
THEY MAY BE DISAGREEING POINTS
OF VIEW BUT WE'LL GET THERE THE
SAME TIME THE SAME WAY THAT WE
DID OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS --
WHEN WE DID AB NINETEEN AT THE
END OF THE DAY DECISION HAS TO
BE MADE?
DO YOU WANT TO USE --
SOME OF THAT MONEY FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SAY THAT FOR A
SECOND OR DO YOU WANT TO GIVE IT
BACK TO STUDENTS TO ENSURE
STUDENT SUCCESS.
SO THE DOLLARS ARE GONNA BE USED
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER THE
DECISION IS HOW THOSE DOLLARS
WOULD BE USED AND WE MAY DIFFER
ABOUT THAT AND AND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WILL RECONCILE THAT SORT
OF THOUGHT.
THAT 11% A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DOLLARS IS GETTING USED ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER IT WILL NOT TOUCH --
THAT PORTION --
BUT 89% TO GO SKATING TWELVE BUT
WHEN AFFECT THE 41% ISSUE WELL
MADE AA APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S
BEEN THE SAID THAT THE HISTORY
IN THE CUSTOM BUT I THINK THERE
IS NOTHING WRITTEN INTO PROP.
NINETY EIGHT CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG THAT --
TO TO TO GUARANTEE --
11% FOR COMMITTEE COLLEGE THE
THAT'S BEEN.
THE THE THE PRACTICE BUT NOT THE
YEAH I THINK I THINK THIS SPLIT
WAS IN PROP NINETY LOCATED OKAY
I GOT THAT CORRECTED. 11% IS
PLANNING IS TEN POINT SOMETHING
ALWAYS THE FUNDING MORE FIRST
HAVE THAT DEBATE AND BUT MR
SANTIAGO SAID.
AT THIS WOULD JUST COME OUT OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PORTION OF
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT BUDGET.
ALL RIGHT WELL LOOK FOR TO A FOR
THE CONVERSATIONS IN THE IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YEAH -- BOTH
FOR SOMEONE THINK THE GOVERNOR
FOR INCLUDING --
THIS -- SOME
OF THIS BUDGET --
INSIDE OF HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
WHICH IS --
ENCOURAGING US IN OF COURSE WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO PUSH THIS
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE LIKE WE
HAVE OVER SEVERAL YEARS ALSO
WANT TO THANK.
US SOME OF THE JOINT AUTHORS AND
CO AUTHORS WILL WORK ON THIS
OVER THE YEARS --
AND OF COURSE THE CHAIR WHO
HELPED US TO GET THIS RIGHT OVER
SEVERAL YEARS WE COULD HAVE DONE
AB NINETEEN THE FIRST ONE
WITHOUT YOUR HELP SOMEONE THANK
YOU FOR THAT --
THE PRINTING BRING MY GLASSES
BUT I HOPE I DO MISS THE NAME
HERE I WANT TO THANK MR BONTA.
CERVANTES CHIU FRIEDMAN.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER --
MCCARTY WHO WE PARTY THANK QUIRK
SILVA.
A GIPSON CARILLO AND THE MISSILE
REVISE CASE I MISSED ANYBODY I
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OF MISSED MCCARTY IT'S ENOUGH TO
ADD [inaudible]
THE LOCATION.
BEFORE I ASK FOR A MOTION --
AS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEE I
SAW THAT THE BIGGEST.
OBSTACLE FOR COMPLETION AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WAS THE NURSE
THE NECESSITY TO WORK. FOR THE
NECESSITY TO EARN MONEY --
SOMETIMES TO SUPPORT A FAMILY SO
AS I VERY MUCH SUPPORTED AB
NINETEEN I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AS WELL.
I I WANT I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
ELSE TO STRIP ACOSTA WE START I
STARTED WITH.
MR MCCARTY AND MISTER MURATSUCHI --
THIS MORNING --
AND SUB.
TO WHERE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
PARENTS WHO WERE.
CONTRIBUTING UP TO HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS TO GET THEIR
CHILD.
INTO A CERTAIN COLLEGE AND I AM
JUST SO IMPRESSED BY MR COSTA.
AND HIS STORY THAT HE SHARES
WITH US ABOUT A FIRST GENERATION
FAMILY WHO COMES TO THIS COUNTRY
TO PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND I THINK HIS STORY IS A
SYMBOLIC.
OF SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE IN THIS
STATE WHO ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THINGS WHOSE PARENTS ARE DOING
THE RIGHT THINGS. TO TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION SO I THINK IT'S
A GOOD ENDING TO THE DAY.
I THANK MISTER COSTA FOR BEING
HERE AND SHARING YOUR STORY MR
SANTIAGO MISTER CHAIR I JUST
FORGOT TO THANK THE ESTATE
CHANCELLOR --
MINUTE MR OAKLEY APOLOGIZE THANK
YOU.
AND SO WE HAVE A AS MOTION BY.
MR LOW.
SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER MAYOR SU CHI
AND BEFORE WE TAKE THE VOTE LET
ME LET ME SAY YOU KNOW I WILL
ECHO.
A MISTER MERCER CHEESE --
COMMENTS ABOUT --
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TO PAY FOR IT AND I KNOW THAT --
WITH THE HELP OF OUR OUR CHAIR
AND SUB TO WHAT WE'LL WE'LL
WE'LL GET TO THAT.
YEAH.
EXACTLY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
LAW AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEEMEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I DALY.
DALY I KILEY.
KILEY NO LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER I ELEVEN ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT AND LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING.
TO GO ON TO ADD ON STEM.
ITEM.
ITEM TO AB ONE FIVE FOUR KILEY.
ONE ONE FIVE KILEY I SO AB ONE
FIFTY FOUR TWELVE ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
AB THREE FIVE SIX KILEY.
KILEY NO PATTERSON [inaudible]
PATTERSON NO.
AB THREE FIFTY SIX TEN TWO THE
BILL IS OUT.
A. B. [inaudible]
THREE EIGHT ONE KILEY.
KILEY I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I AB THREE EIGHTY ONE
TWELVE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
AB FOUR SIX THREE KILEY.
KILEY NO LOW [inaudible]
I AB FOR SIXTY THREE ELEVEN ONE
THE BILL IS OUT.
AB FIVE HUNDRED KILEY
[inaudible]
KILEY NO.
AB FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN ONE THE
BILL IS OUT. EIGHTY FIVE OH FIVE
DALY.
DALY I KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY I AB FIVE OH FIVE TWELVE
ZERO BILL IS OUT.
AB FIVE THREE TWO DALY.
DALY I KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY NO.
AB FIVE THIRTY TO ELEVEN ONE THE
BILL IS OUT.
AB FIVE NINE FIVE DALY.
DALY I KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
PATTERSON PATTERSON I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO II.
AB FIVE NINETY FIVE ELEVEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT.
ACR THIRTY ONE KILEY
[inaudible]
KILEY I EIGHT ACR THIRTY ONE
TWELVE ZERO BILL IS OUT AJ ARE
TO KILEY.
KILEY AYE [inaudible]
AJ ARE. TWO TWELVE ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT.
THIS.
VOTE.
DID I VOTE ON ITEM ONE IN ITEM
THREE BOTH BY SANTIAGO.
I WAS CALLED OUT OF THE MEETING
AT ONE POINT I ITEM ON YOUR I'D.
IN ITEM THREE AMMANAI.
JUST WANTED A BY SANTIAGO JUST
DOUBLE CHECKING YEAH I THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE'RE GOOD.
THERE WERE DURING